scp-682 does it even require an
introduction the SCP Foundation thinks
this cantankerous reptile needs a
serious attitude adjustment by which we
mean they really really want to kill it
but as you might have seen in our
previous videos on the subject they
don't call this monstrosity the hard to
destroy reptile for nothing that's why
we've done what the foundation isn't
allowed to we Outsource the dirty job of
squashing this lizard to all of you we
made a community post asking for your
ideas on how this scaly Abomination can
finally be destroyed and you delivered
Big Time a truly staggering amount with
over 6 000 comments now let's see if we
can finally get our answer because
believe us the foundation is desperate
at this point I don't know what to write
for a name said the most effective way
that Dr bright approves of Chainsaw
Canon as awesome as a chainsaw Canon
would probably be to use it sadly
wouldn't be very effective against
scp-682 chainsaws are blades and we know
from the termination test logs that
blades have been ineffective even when
scp-682 is chopped up into tiny little
pieces those pieces have a nasty habit
of reforming into the big ugly monster
we all know and fear awesome Cardinals
said the SCP Foundation could try to
bring it to the void in Russia where the
pattern screamers are this was a popular
idea and the foundation actually tried
this the SCP being referred to here is
scp-3930 a big old pile of nothing in
Russia that causes things inside it to
stop existing when they threw scp-682
inside it technically did stop existing
despite this it could still be perceived
and still cause the deaths of all
surrounding researchers 15 hours later
it just reappeared in its containment
chamber apparently totally fine you can
probably see why the foundation is
frustrated by this thing scorecard and
friends said black hole need I say more
you may need to say a little more for
starters there would be logistical
issues in actually getting the creature
anywhere near a black hole but there's
also the concern that it may just adapt
its body to respond to the intense
gravity present near a black hole or
even scarier somehow adapt to reproduce
the powers of a black hole it probably
wouldn't be worth the risk of ending up
with a reptile capable of creating gamma
ray bursts Stellar solar Sky said put
the reptile inside nuclear fusion and
watch its particles disappear the
foundation tried something pretty close
to this by trying to put it inside
scp-536 a chamber where they can use
dials to control the physical contents
within they increased the speed of light
and nuclear force within the chamber
which caused scp-682 to disintegrate
until all that was left was a piece of
matter one percent of its original size
however the creature then reformed and
killed killed the researchers later
tests showed that its body had become an
unknown form of matter held together by
Quantum effects impossible to unravel
with our current understanding of
science Brea fund said so you know that
coffee machine thing that is 294 type in
682 killing substance and then repeat
that until you have enough to fill its
entire room then fill it they did
actually try this the resulting
substance was effective in damaging
scp-682's tissue however the one problem
is that it's extremely difficult to
produce enough of this stuff to actually
submerge the creature worse still if
enough was made to cause significant
damage to the body of scp-682 it may
adapt to the chemical as a defense
mechanism making it ineffective as a
weapon its adaptive ability is truly
scp-682's greatest asset when it comes
to thwarting the foundation's constant
attempts to kill it Alex Webb said ask
it kindly to die we don't believe that
the foundation has actually ever tried
this one but just based on the fact that
scp-682 is a huge jerk on top of being
an omnicidal monster he probably
wouldn't respond to polite requests I
Flash Boys said I wonder if Doom Slayer
could defeat the reptile he's torn
through every demon in hell and even
Titans so with 682 be a challenger or
just another Tuesday for the Slayer
that's a slightly trickier one of course
since they exist in different universes
we'll never see an official battle
between the Doom Slayer and scp-682
however given that the Doom slayer's
weapons are all conventional meaning
largely based around slashing crushing
shooting and Blasting we don't know
whether he'd actually be able to slay
the Beast that being said we don't know
if 682 could kill him either we could
have a stalemate on our hands here
Amanda Brenneman said I asked my sister
who's never heard of scp's this question
and her answer was you hit it again
Amanda your sister may be the one to
finally stop this creature getting the
two of them in the same room may be the
biggest logistical problem here Samuel
Pasquale said throwing him down scp-087
so he suffers and is contained once and
for all in the improbable case he is
still alive
scp-087 the endless staircase can be a
dangerous anomaly for humans who don't
know what they're getting into however
scp-682 would likely detect the threat
far earlier than any human and then
breach containment it's definitely
gotten out of stickier situations
yashashiri Shara said send him to
endless Ikea where he will be trapped
forever much like scp-087 the endless
Ikea would impose the same threat to
scp-682 as it would for the average
human trapped inside the staff would be
no trouble for 682 and it would be able
to devote pretty much all of its time in
there to finding a way out and when he
did finally break out he'd probably be
armed with the terrifying knowledge of
how to correctly assemble a spending
throat we shudder at the thought Jack
boss said oxygen Destroyer use to deal
with another big lizard issue back in
1954. sadly this would also likely be an
ineffective weapon against
scp-682 because the creature thrives in
anaerobic environments seeing as its
native atmosphere seems to have no
oxygen and according to Foundation tests
it can survive just fine in a vacuum
whether scp-682 could take Godzilla in a
fight is still up for debate and you can
argue about which lizard would reign
supreme in the comments Ace Goodwin said
just don't kill him let him live bro he
hasn't done anything wrong yet let him
vibe in his chamber wait a second did
scp-682 write this moving on a lot of
you said throw him into the sun while
the sun is a gigantic nuclear furnace
where hydrogen is built into helium at a
temperature of millions of degrees there
is the issue of not only being Beyond
difficult to incapacitate the creature
for long enough to get into the rocket
but also the problem of the sun being 93
million miles away from Earth it's a
long trip there no matter what and
during that time scp-682 would almost
definitely figure out a way to return to
Earth it might even rewire the rocket
and turn it into its own personal
vehicle giving it the freedom to cause
chaos around the solar system and even
if everything else went well
scp-682 would still probably survive
being thrown into the sun after all the
gate guardian's flaming sword is
described as being hotter than the Sun
and it didn't manage to kill the hard to
destroy reptile Pokemon red boy said
send him to Mars and launch a nuke that
can destroy a planet along with the SCP
while a nuke capable of destroying the
planet of Mars would also likely destroy
scp-682 in the process the destruction
of Mars itself would likely cause such a
catastrophic shift in our neck of the
solar system that we'd probably die
along with it the question at that point
is whether it's really worth killing
ourselves to take down the lizard
Artemis said let it live with 999 its
entire life and it's not a threat this
is a double-edged sword during their
cross test
scp-999 did pacify scp-682 and put it in
a state of bliss and laughter for a
brief period however this actually
resulted in a pretty catastrophic
tragedy too 682 adapted to 999's effects
and released a beam of laughter that
incapacitated everyone around it
allowing it to escape and go on a
killing spree so maybe the two are
better kept apart doctor was upset I'd
give 682 a jar of pickles to open and
the jar would be so tight that scp-682
couldn't open it and he would be so
embarrassed by it that he would just
destroy himself you may actually be on
to something here we know we'd be
extremely embarrassed if we couldn't
open the jar but there are three major
problems one where does one get such a
jar can scp-343 make a jar of pickles so
difficult to open that he himself can
open it two we don't know if scp-682
likes pickles enough to make opening the
jar an attractive Prospect and three if
it does turn out that it likes pickles
it would probably just eat the jar too
shuvo battacharji said to deal with him
in my opinion send scp-682 into scp-3001
aka the red reality that's my theory
this could potentially Be an Effective
method of trapping scp-682 for a period
of time however the problem is that
there's no reliable way to access the
red reality the only person who's ever
really been inside is Robert Scranton
and he ended up there completely by
accident so this doesn't seem to be a
reliable neutralization method for
scp-682 adding to that the panel that Dr
Scranton was transported to the red
reality with eventually came back which
means it might only be a temporary
solution anyway mistake to society yay
said Can someone ride scp-682 without
them dying this isn't technically about
neutralizing scp-682 but it deserves an
answer while it appears that some people
are able to ride 682 such as scp-053 the
little girl and 05-6 aka the American in
the orboro cycle he doesn't seem to
enjoy it at least he didn't when scp-082
better known as Ferdinand the cannibal
attempted it of course Ferdinand
describes the relationship quite
differently insisting that 682 is his
Bayard his magical Steed Laura Garcia
said chop it up put the pieces in a
giant bowl with egg beaters stirring it
constantly so it can't reanimate keep it
kinetically moving so it doesn't ever
have the rest time to reform Giant Egg
beating machine to prevent Reformation
killing it would take a rival sunblast
to stop it from reanimating itself this
has got to be one of the most creative
ones we've encountered even Dr Bry
probably wouldn't think to use Giant
whisks on the Beast however it probably
wouldn't kill the ordinary creature for
good as we've said before not only has
the Beast regenerated from things as hot
as the sun he's also able to remain
manifest from the tiniest atoms or even
nothing at all on the plus side he may
reanimate with a new super whisking
ability and could potentially give
scp-5031 a run for best cook and
containment shaked Ben yakar said I
think they need to explode him from the
inside because maybe there's one spot in
this body that isn't invincible and if
they hurt it scp-682 will die the
problem with scp-682 isn't necessarily
that it's Invincible just hyper adaptive
and Hyper regenerative as you may have
seen in other videos
scp-682 has been shot dismembered burned
Frozen vaporized blown up partially
eaten and even totally disintegrated but
it always manages to come back even from
the smallest specs of matter it would
almost be admirable if it wasn't a
perpetually aggressive murder monster
breibot said put it in 106's Pocket
Dimension this actually happened once
during a Containment Breach where the
old man as well as scp-950 3 the
polymorphic humanoid ended up in 682's
cell
scp-106 dragged them all into its pocket
dimension for a bit of the odd
Ultraviolence and when they emerged it
was clear that they'd all taken
considerable damage
scp-682 wasn't killed though and 106
hasn't tried anything like that again
since non-player Cactus said trick him
into killing John Wick's dog to be fair
if anyone could take this monster down
it'd probably be John Wick though
scp-682 might be too smart to actually
kill his dog in the first place and if
he did manage to best John Wick well we
hate to think what a 682 with a marshall
prowess and gun skills of John Wick
would be like actually no we don't need
to think about it because it would be
awesome these are just a little
tasterplate of the huge and varied
potential murder methods you've devised
for this terrible creature but there
were just too many good ones so we'll
have to save the rest for another day
which means it isn't too late to tell us
yours la let us know your idea down in
the comments and make sure to subscribe
turn on notifications and keep an eye on
our community tab so you can be part of
the next video
scp-049 also known as the plague doctor
is an SCP Foundation fan favorite This
Charming anomalous surgeon can terrify
with a glance and kill with a touch in
terms of his Origins his methods and his
thought process around a disease he
calls the pestilence this is one of the
most mysterious scps out there and
thankfully we didn't have to investigate
this one alone we made a community post
asking you the fans of SCP explained to
give us your questions and theories
about the good doctor that we all hope
doesn't give house calls and you didn't
disappoint let's grab our masks and hand
sanitizer and take a look at what you
had to say about
scp-049 first the questions Bob candle
asked why does he refuse to tell
researchers about the pest
that's a good question and also one of
the biggest mysteries surrounding 049's
lore for the uninitiated the pestilence
also known as the great dying is the
nickname given to an unknown disease
that scp-049 has dedicated his life to
curing whatever curing means to him when
asked by Foundation researchers 049
refuses to give up even the most basic
information about the pestilence such as
how he diagnoses it what its effects are
or how it's transmitted it seems that
part of the reason that 049 refuses to
tell researchers about it is that he
apparently assumes that they as fellow
doctors inherently know what he's
talking about when he brings up the
pestilence he has acted with confusion
and frustration during questioning and
049 seems to believe that the pestilence
is such common knowledge among medical
practitioners that it would be a waste
of time to explain it if he even had the
words to do so dadgamer 56 asked why is
he so Cooperative if humans have the
pestilence he wants to cure so bad one
of the most remarkable things about 049
is how reasonable he's been with
Foundation staff in the past he's polite
friendly and treats his jailers as
equals when he's not murdering them and
turning them into zombies but that is a
good question if he believes humans have
the pestilence why is he so Cooperative
with them thankfully the answer here is
simple while 049 believes that the
pestilence is widespread he doesn't
believe that every human is carrying it
in fact when he was first contained by
the foundation and brought into an SCP
facility he complimented the staff on
how little pestilence there was inside
the building compared to the outside
while we don't know what leads 049 to
think a person is healthy or diseased we
do know there is a distinction and he's
Cooperative with those he sees as
healthy star doggo gaming asked how
would he interact with 610 AKA The Flesh
that hates I wonder if he would view the
infected as pestilence another another
great question 610 is an extremely
dangerous sarkic SCP that presents as a
zombie-like virus that causes horrific
fleshy mutations because of the
extremely high infection rate of the
flesh that hates it's been quarantined
in its present location in the isolated
Siberian Wilderness while it would be
too dangerous to bring anyone or
anything into contact with the flesh
we're betting that 049 would find the
flesh utterly repulsive whether even he
would be able to cure this horrific
infection is another question the flesh
that hates is best left alone at all
costs M Cipher 50 asked
scp-049's notebook appears to be written
in a language no human can decipher
could another SCP like 343 or 662 decode
The Notebook the answer to this is a
solid maybe these two scps known as God
and Mr Deeds respectively may be able to
translate the contents of 049's
mysterious leather bound notebook the
problem is given that we've seen 049 is
a pretty terrible doctor when it comes
to anything other than raising mutant
zombies from the dead the contents of
his notebook might just be as useless as
the interviews with him have proven to
be that said it probably is worth a try
just to find out if he's actually been
pretending to write this whole time
Green Angel snake YT asked do other
living creatures like pigs cats or
literally any animal have this thing he
calls the pestilence what even are the
living things he considers cured to the
best of our knowledge 049 only believes
humans can contract the pestilence how
do we know this this leads us to our
next question Mia the hot dog asked if
he touches the immortal lizard will the
lizard die and be rid of disease or will
the lizard be immune or will it attack
the doctor the foundation did attempt to
terminate 682 with 049 but the effort
was unsuccessful zero four nine when
encountering the lizard commented that
only humans can contract the pestilence
when he tried to touch 682 the lizard
swiped at him with its claws 049 then
requested to leave and later interviews
revealed that the plague doctor felt
emotionally disturbed by his time with
682. gamer duck YT asked where did he
originally come from well evidence
suggests that 049 is extremely old and
very well traveled he was first
discovered by the foundation in the town
of montebaum in southern France given
that he speaks fluent medieval French as
his first language it's safe to assume
that France is probably his country of
origin and could have existed for
hundreds of years if not longer
interestingly his famous plague doctor
appearance is more similar to those
first worn by Italian doctors in the
17th century which only deepens the
mystery of
scp-049 Garrett eborn asked why does he
insist that he isn't doing harm when
he's clearly in violation of his
hypocrite oath 049 does seem to regret
the harm he causes but he also believes
that the small sacrifices are necessary
in the quest to cure the pestilence also
a fun little history lesson given that
049's knowledge of medicine appears to
be medieval meaning potentially as early
as the 5th Century he actually would
have predated the Hippocratic Oath
coming into Universal use by doctors
which didn't become widespread until the
19th century despite the oath itself
first being created around 400 BC
Phoenix Fain asked if he has to wear
gloves of any kind would he still kill
you all evidence seems to point to no
only skin to skin contact with 049 is
fatal so a good pair of gloves could
really be a lifesaver Alice Verdugo
asked what would happen if he went
one-on-one with a shy guy would he cure
him or not do anything while we can't
know for sure because scp-096 aka the
shy guy isn't human it's likely that 0
49 wouldn't even consider him infected
if the two came into contact it would
probably result in a stalemate much like
the time scp-096 faced off against
scp-682 however if it did come to blows
between the two 096 is undeniably a much
more dangerous combatant and may be able
to narrowly defeat the plague doctor in
a direct confrontation while in its rage
State anything goes asked if he died
could he bring himself back to life or
have something prepared to bring himself
back to life like a lot of anomalies it
seems that 049 is abnormally hard to
kill given that he's seemingly
impervious to most physical damage
however seeing a 049's resurrection is
both a lengthy medieval process and
never brings its subjects back correctly
it's likely that if someone could
successfully put 049 down he wouldn't
get back up I'm not coming asked we know
that doctors are wearing masks to
protect patients but is his Mass part of
skull or face all of 049's clothes
including his plague doctor mask are
technically part of his body the mask is
part of its bone structure and the other
clothes are like layers of skin which
leads us nicely to the next question
Requiem asked if the clothing around him
is skin does he shut it we're not sure
but it's definitely a thought we all
wish we could forget
oh God now let's take a look at some of
your more interesting theories
clarenceylium theorized pestilence is
sin and he's trying to take it away this
is certainly an interesting Theory while
we can't find much in his file that
suggests 049 views the pestilence as a
result of sinful Behavior or the concept
of sin itself it's worth considering
that his medical background seems to
come from medieval times Medical Science
was in its infancy back then and many
still believe that diseases were the
result of loose morals or even demonic
interference so there might be some
truth to this Theory Thomas has
theorized I feel like he isn't really
bad all he wants to do is help and cure
everyone but his cure is death if we're
defining bad as a malicious desire to
cause harm for its own sake then this
Theory holds a lot of water for all
intents and purposes it does seem that
049 does genuinely want to cure his
patients of the pestilence and he does
seem to express less remorse when they
die however by his own admission his
cure is imperfect and he hasn't found
full success in curing the disease
without causing death yet cat and dog
live theorized the plague doctor has
seen the end of the world and travels in
a loop back in time aiming to eventually
stop it the pestilence is the way each
human's impact on the end of the world
is and once he touches their flesh they
realize this and die of the realization
of what they've done the plague doctor
may be looking for a human or an SCP
that is pestilence-free for what reason
we don't know we don't have an awful lot
to say about this one because there's no
real evidence either way but given that
time travel does seem to be possible in
the SCP Foundation Universe it's a cool
possibility that we definitely can rule
out it does however leave a lot of loose
ends about the gaps in 049's knowledge
such as the fact he doesn't know about
the Black Death Vladimir Lenin theorized
he's the best doctor ever he cures
depression pestilence and sometimes his
patients even come back from the dead
five-star rating this is certainly an
extremely charitable way to view
scp-049 one that he himself would likely
very much appreciate however considering
he changes his patience into mindless
zombified mutants a better course of
action may just be to attend therapy
chaotix theorized the pestilence is
death he is literally trying to cure
death while this could be one
interpretation of y-049 resurrects his
patience as zombies death is something
that affects all living non-anomalous
humans and 049 seems to be selective on
which humans it identifies as being
infected with the pestilence as a result
it is unlikely that the pestilence
refers to death itself and death is also
likely a preferable alternative to being
turned into a zombie by zero four nines
experimental treatments the blue
Guardian theorized the pestilence is an
entity in our Collective unconsciousness
described in
scp-5000 y this is an extremely
interesting Theory and one that could
hold water too if you check out our
series on scp-5000 you'll find that the
foundation discovered a being known as
it hiding inside the collective
unconsciousness of humankind while the
foundation doesn't know about this in
our Dimension it's possible that
scp-049 does and simply doesn't realize
that everyone is infected with it yet
but if this is the case an scp-049
realizes that the whole world is
infected he's likely to become a much
more dangerous anomaly that refuses to
cooperate with anyone moonleaf's 430
theorized the pestilence is the
foundation and 049 is a disciple of the
Scarlet King this is another incredibly
fun Theory however there are two big
problems the first is that 049 has
historically identified people with no
Foundation affiliation is being infected
with the pestilence and the second even
more important issue is that scp-049 is
a highly scientific creature whereas the
Scarlet King hates the very idea of
science with a burning passion as a
result
scp-049 and the Scarlet King are likely
natural enemies and finally zerothrax
theorized his theme song should probably
be Gangsta's Paradise it's just a
speculation though on this Theory we
wholeheartedly agree and there you have
it thanks to everybody who sent in their
great questions and theories about
scp-049 keep an eye on our community
pose to see what anomalous entity we
need your thoughts on next got an SCP
you'd really like us to cover in a video
like this in the future let us know down
in the comments and remember to stay
safe and healthy because if you start
feeling a little under the weather you
can expect a visit from
scp-049 sometime soon it was just a job
you were meant to be mopping floors and
cleaning toilets at the Johnston labs
and pharmaceuticals Research Center for
minimum wage and you were happy about it
grateful for any kind of employment you
didn't even know that the company
signing your checks was the SCP
Foundation an organization dedicated to
securing and containing anomalies and
protecting Humanity from their negative
effects at any cost and today you're
going to find out exactly how steep that
cost can be the Johnston labs and
pharmaceuticals Research Center isn't
actually a research center at all it's a
foundation front business with a
building solely dedicated to the
containment of a single anomaly
scp-3280 but again you're just the
janitor it's not like they would bother
telling you what's being contained here
if it breaks out you won't even know
what's killing you until it's too late
it begins like most classic horror
stories on a dark and stormy night your
mopping up a silent hallway whistling a
little tune to yourself when rain starts
hammering down on the window next to you
not long after you see a bolt of
lightning split the distant Sky followed
by an immense thundercrack soon after
you hear screaming and panicking From
Below frantic footsteps then the
flashing lights and Sirens you think
back to your employee orientation these
flashing lights and wailing Sirens can
only mean one thing Containment Breach
you run for it not even knowing what
you're running from you bring your mop
and bucket with you perhaps just out of
habit you seek refuge in the only place
in the facility that truly seems to
belong to you the broom closet the alarm
blares as you lock yourself in the
closet you're shaking with Terror and
can hear the screaming of your
colleagues you hear more noises running
scrambling a wet dripping sound gunshots
and then silence all this time time you
can't help but wonder why isn't anybody
coming to help us after a while the only
thing you can hear is the rain and the
distant Thunder it's been hours you've
only managed to Stave off dehydration by
drinking the filthy water from the mop
sink but at least it seems like the
chaos outside has died down carefully
you open the door and peek out of the
closet Darkness but no detectable
movement now's your chance and you make
a break for it creeping down the hall
the dark hallway is suddenly lit up by
lightning and you can see that there are
bodies everywhere you step over the
corpse of Dr cothrone one of the few
scientists working here who actually
knew your name if you can make it to the
security office you might be able to
radio for help or maybe access a
computer terminal on the way to the
office you hear another horrific screen
start to echo through the complex before
it's cut off by a Thunderclap you have
to ignore it though and push on when
when you enter the security room you see
that the head security officer Nichols
is already dead his body has been cut
open from neck to groin gutted the
anomaly whatever it is has already been
here you access the computer terminal
and open the file for
scp-3280 you're warned that as
janitorial staff you have level zero
clearance and as a result information
will be omitted from the files you
access it doesn't matter you press on
and open up the file both the object
class and the description have been
redacted you can only see the special
containment procedures they dictate that
3280 is to remain contained at the
Johnston labs and pharmaceuticals
Research Center until long-term
containment procedures can be drawn up
if the entity ever reaches Beyond
sub-level 2 the facility enters full
lockdown mode not even information is
allowed in or out of the facility as
this could result in an XK Class end of
the world since scenario in other words
nobody is coming to save you the only
other information on the page is a
picture of a lightning storm much like
the one you find yourself in right now
lightning flashes in the hall you Dart
around paranoid knowing the anomaly
could be anywhere all you can hear now
is the quiet drip drip drip of blood
coming from the body of security officer
Nichols whatever this thing had done to
him looked painful you try to remember
him as he was in life and then a
revelation hits you a security officer
probably has a lot better clearance than
a janitor you feel around nickels
mutilated torso until you find his key
card thankfully Nichols was the kind of
guy who'd write his password on the
underside of this card so he wouldn't
forget it you easily gain access to the
foundation servers with his login
credentials you now have level 2
security clearance the terminal gives
you the option to view security footage
taken throughout the site you're given
access to every camera still working
after the Containment Breach and the
subsequent Carnage you select the camera
feed for the second floor Barracks there
you see researcher Jensen hanging from a
makeshift news attached to his bunk
there's a puddle underneath his corpse
you access the feed from the second
floor east Wing there you see Dr
Emmanuel stumbling down a dark Corridor
his movements are oddly listless like
he's in the trance suddenly there's
another flash of lightning and a crack
of thunder Dr Emmanuel clutches his gut
in pain and crumples to the floor you
access the camera feed from the first
floor entrance it seems that the whole
area is flooded is this because of the
storm in a panic many lower tier staff
members had tried to escape defying the
lockdown protocols in the special
containment procedures now their
floating face down in the water all dead
you access the camera feed from
sub-level 2 and see another corpse lying
in the corner is wearing an orange
jumpsuit d-class no idea why he was down
there the only other notable thing in
the basement was a burst pipe leaking
and spraying more water everywhere with
trembling fingers you select the camera
feed for the first floor cafeteria the
whole room is practically under water
the only evidence of the massacre that
must have taken place are the fragments
of clothing floating on the surface of
the water that and the fleshy pink
slurry forming at the bottom of the
windows it reminds you of the gooey meat
runoff in chicken nugget factories you
close your eyes and try to Center
yourself it's violent chaos looking at
more of it isn't getting you anywhere
instead you put those new level 2
security access credentials to good use
and hop back onto the file for
scp-3280 you think to yourself there has
to be something I can use on here but
even as you wait for the file to load
some part of you knows that time is
running out for you perhaps it's the
stress or the fear or the filthy mop
water you drink but you're feeling the
pressure start to mount physically your
stomach is beginning to ache you can see
blurry shapes moving in the corners of
your eyes it's getting harder to focus
your vision and harder still to quiet
the terrified voices in your mind but
you can't get up not without knowing
what is doing this to you the
containment class for scp-3280 is now
Declassified Euclid and once more the
special containment procedures have
altered too they now explain that every
week a new member of d-class personnel
is to be deposited into the entities
layer in sub-level 2 through
Subterranean access point gamma the
d-class or more accurately the
sacrifices are to be told lies about why
exactly they need to descend to the
lowest point in the facility they're
even given a working flashlight and a
defensive night stick to create the
illusion that the foundation expects
them them to ever return from the depths
little do they know they also have a
tiny transmitter sewn into their
jumpsuit this broadcasts a frequency
that will attract an eager scp-3280 to
the d-class's location like a dinner
bell only it can hear the file specifies
that scp-3280 always prefers live prey
well at least that explains the dead
d-class in sub-level 2 you think hoping
that it will somehow overwhelm the
dizziness you're feeling or the nagging
pain in your cut you read on somehow the
file's tone becomes even more severe it
says that failure to maintain the
containment of scp-3280 will not only
trigger a lockdown it will always call
in the intervention of two different
mobile task forces MTF Iota 12 the
silencers and tau4 also known as water
water everywhere if 12 hours pass from
the point of initial Containment Breach
and the o5 council hasn't been given the
all-clear signal by one of these teams
preparation Begins for an imminent XK
Class end of the world scenario just
reading the words sends you into a cold
sweat end of the world what on Earth is
this creature finally you reach the
description you get to find out what
this horrifying entity actually is but
the last thing you expect is the first
sentence in the file to read
scp-3280 is a Sapient entity composed of
a fluid physically identical to water
capable of traveling roughly two and a
half kilometers per hour it's water it's
literally a living thinking blob of
water as you read on the concerning
details pile up any water that the
anomalous scp-3280 water touches it
integrates it into its own Mass but
anytime water is separated from this
Mass it remains anomalous and continues
to act independently when the creature
was first discovered it was a mere 66.4
liter in volume now it's around 2500 the
water infected by scp-3280 is hostile to
all humans and not just in a defensive
manner scp-3280 will actively seek out
human prey and when it finds them it
forces its mass into any available body
orifice including the victim's pores
this can happen in such a subtle manner
that you may not even notice yourself
being infiltrated but below this the
file has a list of symptoms for those
experiencing 3280 infiltration loss of
motor control weakening of the
micturition reflex visual hallucinations
and abdominal pain as you read the words
your stomach gives another painful churn
almost like something is moving around
inside of you it's all coming together
you read on the file states that
scp-3280 is so difficult to contain
because it exhibits claustrophobic
Tendencies anytime it's placed inside a
container whether organic or inorganic
it escapes with pressurized water jets
that travel at over 255 miles per hour
if the water is inside a human it may
literally explode out of them killing
them in the process your jittering eyes
turn to the gutted body of security
officer Nichols it all makes sense now
everything is becoming clear as the pain
in your stomach builds in its intensity
the file goes on to say that if scp-3280
escapes sub-level 2 it may be impossible
to contain again if 3280 ever escaped
the site proper it would indeed cause an
XK Class end of the world scenario to
unfold as 3280 merged with our water
cycle and destroyed all of Humanity on a
global scale it would become truly
impossible for anyone to escape you
can't read anymore the pain in your
stomach is unbearable you jerk from your
seat and stumble out into the Hall
doubled over in agony you can feel it
pulsing in there fighting its way out
and must have gotten in through the
filthy mop water you were drinking you
didn't even know it but your fate has
been sealed for hours you've been a dead
man walking the hum of pain builds in
your ears and renders you almost death
all you can hear is the pattern of rain
and distant Thunder you collapse against
the glass feeling the coolness of it
against the skin of your face and in
that moment you see the water droplets
on the window pane reverse Direction
they're slithering up the glass towards
your face in defiance of gravity then
you realize it's all over and not just
for you
scp-3280 has escaped it's out there and
it's going to drown the entire world as
you collapse to your knees and prepare
to be torn apart from the inside your
final thought is that at least you won't
be alive to see it your new SCP
Foundation researcher on tour of site 17
familiarizing yourself with the location
and its many anomalous inhabitants it's
the second largest Foundation
containment site out there and it's also
the kind of job that most Junior
researchers dream of low risk humanoid
containment baby most of the inhabitants
in your sector are cordial willing to
comply with orders from staff and seeing
for all intents and purposes pretty much
human you pass from door to door looking
through the viewing hatch of each one
you can't believe what you're seeing
it's a wonderful who's who of anomalous
humanoids you see the wise bearded face
of scp-343 known to some as God you see
the blue eyes and Shining blonde hair of
Iris as cp105 looking wistfully into a
Polaroid picture you see the tanned
melancholic face of Kane
scp-073 as he stares off into the middle
distance face after face after face
passes you can see yourself getting more
familiar with each one yes your time
here will be wait was that Hitler you
stop and walk back to the door you just
past where you can't help but stop and
stare in disbelief yes it's him It's
gotta be him you recognize the
unpleasant sneer the Hideous comb over
the silly little toothbrush mustache the
SCP Foundation seems to have Adolf
Hitler the former leader of the Third
Reich in World War II in active
containment and his designation is
scp-2430 you've seen Killer toasters and
masks that can take over people's minds
but you've never seen anything as
surreal as this you immediately run to
your Superior and ask how and why Hitler
is in one of the site-17 humanoid
containment cells Buckle in because we
can guarantee it's one of the most
insane stories you've ever heard it's
late April 1945 and the Soviets are
rampaging through Nazi Germany
destroying everything in their path the
German forces have been nearly
obliterated and Hitler and the rest of
his Reich chancellory have retreated to
a secure bunker beneath Berlin there on
April 30th 10 days after his 56th
birthday Hitler died this was truly
unfortunate for the Soviets as they wish
to have had the chance to kill him
themselves two days later Soviet forces
stormed the fury bunker it was little
more than a formality at that point as
the news of Hitler's death had already
gone public by the time they arrived all
that was left of Hitler was a pile of
mostly burnt remains A fitting end for
someone who had caused the same cruel
fate for so many others they collected
what was left of Hitler's body and
brought it back to the Fatherland a kind
of trophy for their Nation but Hitler
dying before Joseph Stalin could get his
hands on him was not what Stalin wanted
Hitler had not only caused the deaths of
millions of Russians he had personally
betrayed Stalin's trust and when you
betray Stalin bad things happened to you
very very bad thing
two years earlier in 1943 Soviet forces
had raided the camp in genowiska
belonging to the obscura Corps think of
them as the Nazi's own version of the
SCP Foundation who were hell-bent on
Gathering anomalous people and artifacts
to increase the power of the Third Reich
they were a far more militant offshoot
of the tool Society a group that
described itself as a study group for
Germanic Antiquity while this may seem
innocent the Teo Society was actually a
racist cult closely aligned with the
goals and ideas of the German Nazi party
many have also speculated that they were
heavily involved in the occult and it's
this mysticism obsessed offshoot that
went on to form the obscura Corps and in
their genowaska base they'd obtained a
hundred pieces of Enchanted occult flesh
with human skeletons embedded in each of
them this flesh was believed to
originate from the mythological surimner
the Beast hunted and eaten again and
again by the pantheon of Norse gods
having the qualities of both a wild boar
War and the Goat the flesh can bond to
skeletons and give them equality
somewhat like immortality any flesh cut
from them will regrow time and time
again if given a rest period now that he
had both the Flesh of surimner and
Hitler's burnt remains Stalin had an
idea a perfect way to not only bring
satisfaction to the Russian people and
the world but to finally exact the true
Revenge that Hitler had denied to him he
called it project judica namely after
the very bottom level of Hell reserved
for betrayers like Judas a perfect
tribute for an old Ally turned enemy he
couldn't kill Hitler before but if
Stalin was going to get the chance
Hitler needed to live again for years
Stalin's top scientists try to use
Arcane methods to resurrect Hitler by
combining his remains with the Flesh of
suramir at times they even came close to
creating a new Hitler but there was one
huge issue the creature they created
could not feel pain and for Stalin's
plans of violin and painful retribution
the lack of suffering simply would not
do they destroyed what they had created
and went back to the drawing board
Stalin would stop at nothing to get what
he wanted even if it meant breaking
every law of nature in the process in
order to make his Twisted dream a
reality Stahl informed an Unholy
alliance with a group known as the
uralic flesh Crafters a neo-sarcic cult
that was a branch of the nightmarish
religion of sarcasism this group
essentially worships avatars of Flesh
corruption and disease and are behind
some of the most terrifying and
disgusting anomalies out there including
the flesh that hates and the bone
Orchard true sarcasists who show the
proper Devotion to their vile deities
and know the right rituals to contact
them are often granted anomalous powers
that spread the sarkic influence further
across the known Dimensions these Powers
will usually involve having a
supernatural ability to manipulate the
Flesh of themselves and others allowing
them to enhance their bodies cheat death
and warp their enemies Beyond repair
they can sometimes even create life if
they're a powerful enough acolyte of
psychicism and it was because of these
powers that Stalin wanted the erotic
flesh Crafters under his command in
exchange for their participation he
would give them a vast quantity of the
Flesh of suramir which they could use
for their own Sinister sarkic purposes a
deal was struck and the true work of
resurrecting Hitler began Stalin was
very specific in his requirements he
gave the uralic fleshcrafters extra
bones to compensate for what had gone
missing from Hitler's burnt remains he
also gave them samples of the Flesh of
saramir to achieve the desired effects
of a near Immortal tolerance for damage
however Stalin demanded that he
heightened this new Hitler's capacity to
experience pain so that every suffering
inflicted on him would be three times
worse than anyone else and true to their
word the flesh Crafters got to work and
began began creating just such a
creature by now it was the early 1950s
and Stalin was putting the pieces in
place for his Grand Revenge once the new
Hitler was finished he would hold a new
trial for him in the Russian courts
where he would preside over the
sentencing personally once the new
Hitler was done the erotic fleshcrafters
were rewarded for their participation in
Project Utica with four thousand
kilograms of the Flesh of suramir Stalin
now had his very own personal Hitler
chew toy that he could maim and torture
as much as he pleased knowing that he
would always heal and soon be ready for
more in their infinite generosity the
fleshcrafters even taught Stalin a new
method of Torment for his old enemy a
process known as the right of nyas it's
a torture that's been described by many
as being like the Chinese Ling Chi also
known as the lingering death or slow
slicing but it is probably best known as
the death by a Thousand Cuts the Soviets
and the sarkix parted ways for the next
next few years Stalin took a great deal
of pleasure in visiting Hitler's cage
now and then to torture him until Stalin
himself eventually passed away from
natural causes the grup division which
is essentially the Soviet answer to the
SCP Foundation decided it would be best
to do away with the immortal Hitler
clone after Stalin's death he no longer
served any purpose and no matter how
hard they tried they couldn't
permanently kill him either in the end
they settled on a kind of compromise he
would be buried alive and forgotten
forced to live a torturous eternity that
he could never Escape until of course he
was dug up and rescued by none other
than the members of obscura a modern
splinter group of the original obscura
corpse like many high-profile Nazis
who'd escaped the war the new Hitler was
Spirited Away to a safe house run by
sympathizers in Argentina the ones
taking care of him received the
following correspondence from the
obscura agents who'd first dug the new
Hitler back up they have managed to
rescue zafira and bring him to safety
but he is effectively dead on the inside
I blame the Reds for their inhumane
treatment of the Fiora who may have been
Bewitched by the Reds vandevath I wish
we could mercy kill him but we've tried
everything he just won't perish don't
abandon him he's too distinct in plain
sight they didn't have the new Hitler
for long though in 1960 efforts to hunt
down the remaining Nazi fugitives
increased in intensity the new Hitler
was soon captured by Mossad agents
searching for Nazis in Buenos Aires and
then remanded to the containment of the
SCP Foundation when they realized that
he had a number of anomalous properties
such as his incredible regenerative
abilities as well as the fact that his
DNA seems to be based on that of a wild
boar and a goat rather than a human
however x-rays conducted by the
foundation have discovered traces of
cyanide still in his system as well as
traces of lead in his skull where the
bone has regrown over the bullet in
other words it was unquestionably the
real Hitler and he was now in Foundation
custody forevermore it's such a wild
story even by Foundation standards that
you can barely summon the words to
respond once your supervisor is finished
he just stands there with a slight smile
basking in your amazement before you can
even ask again he confirms the facts one
more time yes it is the real Hitler the
only functional difference is that he
can't die and he has a heightened sense
of pain compared to most people you
think on what you've been told for just
a moment and then you have only one
question are we allowed to punch him
your supervisor smiles and says of
course we all do are you sitting
comfortably we know a good chair is hard
to find maybe you're watching this on
your phone while you lie in bed or maybe
you're watching at your desk sitting in
an office chair maybe you're even
watching it while you're in the bathroom
it's fine we're not here to judge for
our money you just can't beat a nice
classic wooden chair with soft leather
upholstery call us old-fashioned but
some some things just never go out of
style take a chair like
scp-1609 for example this fine piece of
mahogany was once a chair that simply
couldn't be beat in its quest to bring
its users a little dose of comfort and
refinement in their daily life tell us
have you ever been on your feet all day
just walking and walking and walking and
at a certain point you're just begging
for a nice comfy chair that'll let you
take the weight off your feet for a
little while you would have been
scp-1609's favorite kind of person after
all it was the only chair that literally
sought out weary Travelers and even did
you the courtesy of tucking itself in
that's not a metaphor either
scp-1609 could literally teleport to
nearby people who needed to sit down and
didn't have a chair to fulfill that
desire it was nothing but a nice helpful
anomaly that wanted to help people rest
when they needed it most the more
observant members of you have noticed
that we've been using the past 10 so far
that's because while
scp-1609 is still an active anomaly it
isn't a chair anymore and this
transformation wasn't something that
scp-1609 planned anticipated or even
wanted the story of 1609's
transformation even strikes to the core
of one of the foundation's oldest and
most bitterly held rivalries with
another group of interest it's the tale
of how a helpful piece of anomalous
Furniture became a paranoid killer but
first we need to talk about containment
procedures like a word you see so often
that it starts to lose meaning
containment and specific containment
procedures are Concepts so integral to
the very existence of the SCP Foundation
that it is easy to overlook or forget
about them they're one of the Three core
pillars of the foundation's mission
statement secure contain protect because
of the centrality of containment to the
foundation's core principles one of the
most valuable roles on the S CP
Foundation payroll is that of the
containment specialist a vast team of
experts who work with researchers to
figure out the best way to keep every
anomaly contained based on their unique
abilities and attributes their
zookeepers archivists guards security
and intelligence experts magicians
practitioners of ritual scientists and
so much more in short they're anything
they need to be in order to adapt to the
ever-evolving containment needs of the
anomalies they keep under lock and key
and containment isn't easy aside from
the rare safe class scps which require
incredibly minimal containment resources
the containment of most scps extracts
some kind of cost whether that be
Financial time effort or in some
particularly dark cases human life some
scps like
scp-974 and
scp-2845 require the sacrifice of human
children to prevent worse Fades
befalling many others other scps like
the infamous scp-231 require the
foundation to do horrifying things to
the SCP itself to prevent it from
manifesting some even more horrifying
anomalous traits and a third but equally
inconvenient kind of SCP like scp-682
and
scp-076 require huge numbers of heavily
armed guards with powerful weapons to
keep their deadly prisoners locked away
often at a massive risk to their own
lives containment isn't easy but it's
ultimately the very thing that makes the
SCP Foundation the organization it is if
they were instead on a quest to kill and
destroy every anomaly they could get
their hands on then they'd be the global
occult Coalition the un's answer to the
SCP Foundation that prefers to seek
disable and Destroy rather than secure
contain and protect it's the primary
characteristic that differentiates these
two Titans of the anomalous world who
regularly come to blows and right at the
heart of that difference is
scp-1609 as we mentioned earlier
scp-1609 went through a transformation
that changed everything but the SCP
Foundation never actually knew about the
anomaly prior to that transformation
taking place it first came to their
attention when it literally manifested
within a containment cell in storage
site-08 making the rare move of
willingly submitting itself to the
foundation containment but what showed
up in that cell certainly wasn't a chair
when 1609 appeared all it looked like
was a pile of trash specifically
splinters wood chippings furniture nails
and scraps of bleached leather and
fabric anything that suddenly
infiltrates a secure Foundation
containment scientists cause for concern
even a bunch of wood scraps so the site
director sent in an armed guard to
investigate the mysterious pile of
debris researchers watching over
surveillance feed were surprised when
the guard suddenly entered a state of
heightened distress he fell to his knees
coughing and spluttering until he
expelled the considerable amount of
blood from his mouth and nose he then
collapsed on the ground next to the pile
of debris dead an investigation
following this incident found that the
guard had died after a sudden influx of
jagged metal and wood had teleported
inside of him tearing his lungs apart
from the inside and causing the guard to
die a painful and horrific death
naturally the sight Personnel were
somewhat concerned by this development
they sent in a d-class to investigate
further but were surprised to find that
the d-class in question was somehow
completely fine the pile of debris that
would soon be designated
scp-1609 made no attempt to harm the
d-class as it had the guard and finding
out why this was the case came as a side
effect of figuring out exactly what had
happened to
scp-1609 through a rigorous
investigation and involving more than
one secret Foundation mole they
discovered that scp-1609 had previously
been in the possession of you guessed it
the global occult Coalition back then it
was just a helpful chair you once knew
and loved until the GOC had the bright
idea of forcing it into a wood chipper
in order to destroy it due to its
connection to someone called the
carpenter but all the gocs attempt
actually succeeded in doing was altering
its form and completely changing its
personality to put it in simple terms
scp-1609 is now a pile of possibly
sentient teleporting wood and metal
chippings that suffers from a nasty case
of PTSD the incident with the wood
chipper traumatized
scp-1609 and its anxiety is triggered by
anything that reminds it of the GOC or
the wood chipper incident this includes
wearing formal clothing lab coats
protective clothing jumpsuits and
particularly body armor but also
includes anyone care carrying weapons
appearing outwardly aggressive using
common GOC lingo or even mentioning the
GOC in
scp-1609's proximity if any of this
happens it's extremely likely that
scp-1609 will resort to its only natural
defense mechanism which is teleporting
its debris into the lungs of anyone it
considers to be a threat the guard had
received this grisly punishment because
his clothes weapon and overall manner
cost
scp-1609 to regard him as a threat and
react accordingly you may think this is
overkill on 1609's part but if you were
just trying to help out the chairless
people of the world then someone fed you
into a wood chipper you'd probably be a
little jumpy too since these early days
the foundation has learned to apply a
more Tender Touch when it comes to
dealing with scp-1609 and the brilliant
containment Specialists even figured out
a way to keep 1609 happily contained by
placing it in a flower bed inside its
containment chamber where its wood chips
get to service mulch for a variety of
flowers and plants all attending
researchers and guards dress in plain
clothes and adopt a loose Pleasant
attitude while inside whenever they're
around they make a point of saying how
beautiful the flower bed is so that the
disfigured anomaly that only ever wanted
to be helpful can still feel like it's
doing something nice because of these
containment procedures breaches
involving scp-1609 have remained in the
single digits it is a perfect example of
less really being more when it comes to
containment the head researcher on the
scp-1609 case Dr sievert released an
internal document permanently affixed to
the file like a kind of cautionary
signpost it's a clear expression of
exasperation and rage at the actions of
the global occult Coalition reading
scp-1609 represents a perfect example of
a flaws inherent in the operating
procedure of the GOC and serves as a
cautionary tale for any members of the
found Foundation who disagree with our
practices on containing dangerous
objects prior to the Coalition getting
their hands on this it was perfectly
harmless a chair which teleports to you
when you need to see it as normal
compared to most of the stuff that we
deal with on a regular basis when they
put it through a wood chipper they got
hurt scared and angry so it lashed out
at them by trying to protect the World
by destroying it they inadvertently made
the situation a whole lot worse
scp-1609 went from being harmless to
deadly in the space of a few minutes
because of the GOC and we had to clean
up the mess thankfully scp-1609 is
pretty simple for us to deal with so
long as we don't have to do anything
stupid around it we won't fight back and
it won't try to leave even if it does it
usually comes back and I think I've
worked out why it came to us because it
was afraid of the people who had heard
it that's why it always comes back it's
afraid of the rest of the world now and
it's looking to us for protection this
is is why we have special containment
procedures instead of special
destruction procedures if you break
something it's broken forever when you
try to destroy an anomaly you can't take
back your mistakes that's what scp-1609
has to tell us this is why we're right
and the GOC is wrong people but of
course there are two sides to every
story and it's important to understand
the gocs perspective on this whole mess
to them this has never been
scp-1609 it's
kte0937 velvetine aka the sixth chair it
was labeled as the sixth because for the
GOC this chair was merely one part of a
wider investigation it belonged to a
six-piece furniture set created by a
dangerous anomalous Person of Interest
named the carpenter for a classified
customer the GOC was able to intercept
this deal and kill the Carpenter and his
customer in the process after that all
that was left was to eliminate the
anomalous objects and five of them were
incinerated without incident however
before they could do the same to the
sixth chair they experienced an
incinerator malfunction rather than just
waiting for the incinerator to be fixed
a member of GOC Personnel decided to
rush the job and run the chair through a
wood chipper it was at this point that
it's pieces first lashed out invading
the lungs of this negligent GOC member
along with five others killing them all
it was shortly after that that
scp-1609 manifested in Foundation
containment much like Dr severt did for
the foundation assistant director
Kipling one of the gocs Legion of middle
managers a fixed a note to the profile
of
kte0937 velvetine that reads
kte-0937 velvetine is an object lesson
in the importance of following proper
operating procedures due to the lack of
vigilance by the agent on the scene the
object's Threat Level was escalated the
object itself was not successfully
disposed of and it has since fallen into
the hands of a hostile agency as single
failure by a single operative resulted
in the deaths of six remember this next
time you think about cutting corners and
that's a good lesson for everyone
whether you're trying to destroy an
anomalous piece of furniture or keeping
its remains happy so they don't try to
kill you cutting Corners is always a
fast track to failure you've finally
done it after years of adding movies and
shows to your cues you've officially run
out of things to watch on Netflix you've
also exhausted your entire backlog of
books and you've even run out of cereal
boxes to read so you're left roaming the
streets in search of entertainment
that's when you see a worn looking flyer
stapled to a nearby telephone pole it's
an ad for a local community theater
production of a play you've never heard
of a play called the hanged Kings
tragedy normally you wouldn't think of
yourself as much of a theater person but
something about the art on the poster
grabs you there's a strange figure on
the poster its face shroud it its body
wrapped in a web of chains your
curiosity gets the better of you and you
check the performance date to your
pleasant surprise opening night is a
week from now and you don't have
anything planned you've made up your
mind you're going to attend a live
performance of the hanged King's tragedy
it's going to be the first live play
you've ever seen and little do you know
it may also be the last because the Hang
King's tragedy isn't just any old play
it's a powerful and deadly memetic
Hazard that may be one of the gateways
to an even more dangerous being it's
known to the SCP Foundation as
scp-701 so take your seats be sure to
read your programs thoroughly and
prepare for the dark and terrifying tale
of the hanged King's tragedy and the
wave of death and destruction it causes
in its theatrical wake but how could you
know any of this while you head home to
make dinner looking forward to seeing
the new playing next week the local
thespians are hard at work performing
dress rehearsals the director one Marcus
Finch happened upon a copy of the play
while looking for Carolinian theater
that's a little more family friendly
than some of the Shakespearean Classics
when he'd first discovered the hanged
King's tragedy on a theatrical Forum it
was described as being similar to
Shakespeare's Hamlet and Titus
andronicus but the violence was largely
off stage and implied with a lot of the
play's nastier elements glossed over
perfect for audience of all ages given
the fact that performances of the Hang
Kings tragedy tend to be mass casualty
events for reasons you'll soon see the
foundation does everything they can to
control the spread of the play's script
all copies are kept in a triple locked
vault in a secure Foundation archive
which currently includes two copies of
the original publication that are dated
to the years 1640 27 copies of the 1965
trade paperback edition 10 copies of a
1971 hardcover printing 21 floppy
diskettes containing the place script
and one svhs video cassette tape
containing a live taping of one
particularly Infamous incident however
this seemingly does little to prevent
new performances of the hanged King's
tragedy from occurring the text of the
play continually pops up online often
under different or misspelled titles
preventing Foundation web crawlers from
keeping track of them all nevertheless
the foundation does everything in its
power to detect and stop performances
before they can go ahead the danger of
putting on or even viewing a performance
of The Hang King's tragedy cannot be
overstated it's believed that in the
almost 300 years since its original
publication it's claimed ten thousand
lives through performances at the very
least and if you're in attendance dying
quickly is one of the better outcomes
the origins of this mimetic virus are
just as mysterious as the power that
seems to drive its effects the plane
never had a declared author and the
publisher one William Cook disappeared
from all historical records after the
play's Publications performances have
been varied over the 300 years the play
has been active it's been spotted
everywhere from British University drama
troops to American High School plays in
what could have been an even more
disastrous tragedy a television
adaptation of the play was almost
broadcast by the BBC before the
foundation stepped in and put a stop to
it while its containment classification
is currently Euclid scientists who have
studied the play have campaigned
strongly to upgrade the Hang King's
tragedy to Cutter class on account of
its unpredictability and tendency to
manifest across the globe with
incidences appearing decades apart while
members of the o5 council are skeptical
some researchers even believe that given
a wide enough exposure the Hang King's
tragedy could cause a dreaded XK Class
end of the world scenario it is that
dangerous at this point you're probably
wondering what exactly is the Hang
King's tragedy what's the play even
about as the name suggests the play is a
tragedy and takes place over five acts
during the Carolinian era portraying the
drama of the Royal Court much like a
number of plays from that time did it
takes place in the city of circo the
capital of the mysterious fictional
Kingdom of trinkula the focal point of
the play is the conflict between gonzola
the illegitimate king of trinkolo and
Antonio the true heir to the throne
before the start of the play the
previous king of trinkula King sephorza
had been betrayed and murdered by
Gonzalo Gonzalo led zaforza into the
woods where he and his men subdued the
king and hanged him from a nearby tray
like a common criminal hence the hanged
King's tragedy however Gonzalo is trying
to keep his part in the king's murder a
secret to keep the throne for himself
but his guild-stricken wife Isabella
threatens to Spill The Secret of
Sephora's murder while Antonio tries to
uncover the truth of what happened in
the woods Gonzalo in true Shakespearean
villain's style plots further murders of
his co-conspirators and loose ends to
keep his Dark Secrets safe this is where
the play gets a little gruesome one
enemy Gonzalo had killed and cooked into
a stew he then intends to use this stew
to murder his entire court with the help
of an effective and undetectable poison
he was given by the mysterious
ambassador of alagada though you'll be
pleased to know that this tragedy has
somewhat of a happy ending in the end
Gonzalo was exposed and Antonio claims
his rightful place as king of trinkulo
unlike his predecessor Antonio decides
to show mercy and Gonzalez low is exiled
to a monastery for life rather than
being executed for his murderous ways
the heroes are rewarded the villains are
punished and all the deserving parties
live happily ever after at face value
nothing seems off about the play if
you're familiar with other works of the
era you might even find yourself getting
bored while reading it how can something
this normal be the curse play that
claims so many thousands of lives but
this plays on assuming nature only
serves to make it more dangerous it
doesn't appear that the memetic hazard
is caused by simply reading the play
like all good theater it only truly
comes to life on stage and your local
production of the Hang Kings tragedy is
no exception as your community's amateur
actors study and rehearse the play
making sure to commit every scene every
line every single word to memory they
don't notice the little things that to
an outsider might seem seem a little off
occasionally during group dress
rehearsals actors will Veer from the
script and we're not talking about flub
lines or simple improvisation no actors
will at times seem like they're reading
from a completely different script and
their fellow performers will respond in
kind the play lulls you into a false
sense of security stagehands crew
members even the director all believe
they're performing the play exactly as
it was originally written okay so that's
not so bad a play that changes itself
but things are going to get worse from
this point much much worse but hey why
let a deadly anomaly ruin your evening
plans you've been looking forward to
seeing this play all week and you
couldn't seem to get that figure from
the poster out of your mind you have no
idea that this entity is wanted by the
SCP Foundation and that its designation
is
scp-701-1 all you want is an
unforgettable theater experience and you
will certainly get one it's a packed
house not an empty seed in sight the
house lights dim and the curtain opens
act one is quite normal with all the
backstabbing and Royal Court Intrigue
you'd expect you actually feel yourself
getting a little bored a big yawn
escapes your mouth you're thinking that
maybe this was a big mistake and you
might sneak out between acts when just
then you see it in the final scene of
act one you see the shrouded figure
lingering in the background against the
curtains he seems so still he's almost
like a shadow but as each Act seems to
run into the next he becomes more
prominent the rest of the cast Never
acknowledges him as they deliver
dramatic monologues but he's always
there finally the play reached Act five
the Grand Banquet scene where it all
comes to head Gonzalo is preparing to
poison his dinner guests with his
cannibal stew while Antonio and his
allies plot to reveal his terrible
crimes and Dethrone him you find
yourself so gripped by the drama of it
all you almost didn't notice that the
shrouded figure of
scp-701-1 was standing right among the
actors now while unbeknownst to you the
actors have been deviating from the
scripted story this whole time things
are about to really take a turn for the
horrific
scp-701-1 who is now known to the other
performers as the hanged King produces a
blade from thin air and passes it to the
actor playing gonzalo's wife the actors
on stage suddenly become entranced they
attack and restrain Gonzalo and a noose
drops down from somewhere above the
stage the actors proceed to
ritualistically hang Gonzalo before the
actor playing his wife stabs him to
death all while chanting blood for the
hanged King you should be horrified but
you're not you don't even feel like self
anymore and you're loving everything
that's happening on stage a series of
other nooses fall from above each actor
grabs their own noose and the cast
repeats blood for the hanged King before
sacrificing their lives to the Shroud
wearing monster if the Carnage stopped
there it would be bad enough but this
play doesn't just drive its players to
acts of violent Insanity it pulls in the
audience too before you know it you're
pulled into a vicious brawl with your
fellow theater goers there's biting
clawing punching people hitting each
other with chairs like it's a wrestling
cage match it's such a frenzy of random
senseless violence that the building
can't contain it anymore you and anyone
else who isn't dead already Spilled Out
onto the streets and start attacking
everyone you can get your hands on it's
transformed from a pleasant night out at
the theater into a full-blown Riot even
the police sent in to control the
situation are overwhelmed it isn't until
the SCP Foundation sends a number of
mobile task forces trained in advanced
crowd control that the situation finally
begins to de-escalate but you don't care
even when large men in Foundation
tactical gear are holding your arms you
still try to bite and kick the effects
of the play normally wear off after
around 24 hours but until then the
infected including you are just rage
fueled monsters in the end it takes four
adult men to properly restrain you
you'll feel the bruises from their night
sticks tomorrow but now all you feel is
hate and violence and a single-minded
Devotion to something out there that you
couldn't possibly comprehend and the
whole time you're screaming one thing
over and over again blood for the hanged
King there's a monster under my bed
almost every parent has heard their kids
make the claim and it's usually nothing
more than some unusual Shadows or at
worst a household pest scurrying around
parents usually tell their child to go
back to sleep or maybe try to dispel
their fears by shining a light under the
bed it's a childhood ride of Passage and
one that usually passes soon enough but
for one young woman in Missouri the
monster under her bed was very real and
very dangerous
scp-3887-a doesn't seem like she belongs
in a containment facility she's a 24
year old woman who lived a quiet life in
her hometown until things went horribly
wrong she doesn't appear to possess any
special abilities and the foundation is
able to contain her without any
difficulty but wherever she goes death
and destruction follow it's not her
doing but there is something out there
that will not stand to see her hurt in
any way her personal monster under the
bed is very protective something another
young woman found out the hard way
incident
3887-8-1 occurred in 2014 when the young
woman was attending a party with her
girlfriend her partner was berating and
humiliating her in front of the guests
which was apparently not a rare
occurrence in their relationship
suddenly something manifested under a
nearby table and before she could react
her girlfriend was brutally mauled by
the unknown creature her limbs were
completely severed from her body and she
died at the scene an undercover a CP
agent who was implanted within the local
authorities made their way to the scene
as soon as possible and found
scp-3887-a in a State of Shock and who
could blame her after the encounter she
just had with what would become to be
known as
scp-3887-b while
3887-a is a normal human with no unusual
abilities or characteristics
3887-b is anything but Foundation
scientists have described it as a
humanoid entity standing over seven feet
tall its skin is greenish gray and it
has two long sharp horns on its head its
head and neck are covered in thick black
hair and its eyes are a striking yellow
color its mouth is full of sharp fangs
similar to that of a shark and its
elongated arms allow it to move on all
fours it has a long hairless tail that
resembles a rats and possesses both male
and female reproductive organs no one
knows where it came from but they do
have an idea why it's sticking around
scp-3887-b seems to be bonded to
scp-3887-a and can appear in any
darkened area within a 5 meter radius
around her while its favorite location
is under
3887-a's bed which has since been been
brought to the facility it appears to be
able to teleport wherever she is just as
it did during the party where it made
its presence brutally clear it has odd
eating patterns and is able to gain
nourishment from practically any object
whether it resembles what we would
consider food or not its favorite treats
for example
scp-3887-a's socks but it does have one
weakness that has been useful in
containing it it can't stand the light
and it doesn't just hate it when
scp-3887-b is exposed to Bright Light it
develops blisters and wounds and fleas
to the nearest dark area SCP Foundation
scientists are at a loss to explain
exactly what this creature is though and
scp-3887-b seems to be a chimera of
multiple animals with multiple types of
DNA it possesses DNA similar to humans
but also from a type of oryx with
similar horns as well was a rat with the
same type of tail as well as a common
cane toad and there's even some DNA that
doesn't resemble any creature in nature
studying it further has been trickier
though because it seems to have the
effect of disrupting any electronic
recording devices near it causing
lasting damage if it's in proximity to
them for too long there has been one
good bit of news for SCP scientists
though because while it has shown that
it can be extremely violent it has not
attacked Foundation officials not yet at
least its good behavior may not have
anything to do with how it personally
feels about Foundation staff though and
is instead all thanks to
scp-3887-a
3887-a has been completely Cooperative
since she was taken into custody by the
foundation she doesn't perceive them as
a threat and so far it seems like
scp-3887-b is following her lead it has
a strong emotional connection to to the
young woman and when they're alone they
show affectionate Behavior towards each
other while the creature does not seem
to like the foundation it doesn't seem
like it wants to become hostile until
the foundation gives it a reason to when
3887-a was interviewed following the
tragic incident by undercover Foundation
agent Bellamy she was panicked and
terrified she admitted that her partner
often treated her badly and believed
that the creature was trying to protect
her she admitted that she had seen the
creature before she even had a name for
it she called her Brenda
3887-shay thought she was crazy now
there was proof though she was not
Imagining the monster under her bed
describing Grenda as her Boogeyman the
young woman talked about how she had
known the creature since she was a child
she grew up in an old house in the
country that was full of strange sounds
that made it sound like something was in
her room with her and sometimes she
would even catch a glimpse of what she
thought was a monster under her bed
watching her she tried telling her
parents what they thought she was making
the whole thing up and even she was
forced to wonder if she was
hallucinating or had somehow imagined
the whole thing but then when she was a
teenager all of her doubts were put to
bed one night
3887-8's parents were loudly fighting a
sadly not rare occurrence in their
household and she locked herself in her
room to get away from them as she hid
Grenda emerged from under her bed for
the first time and talked with her and
she isn't the only one that Grenda is
willing to speak with she's also sat
down for her own interviews with
Foundation researchers well the
researchers sat down while Grenda
remained under the bed Foundation
researcher Dr Tanner interviewed Grenda
who was cordial but guarded and remained
deeply protective of the girl under her
protection she expressed feeling guilty
for getting
3887-a in trouble but Dr Tanner assured
her that 3887-a was not being punished
and was being kept at the foundation for
her own safety he offered that they
could keep Grenda safe as well but she
responded that as long as
3887-8 remains safe then she would be as
well she explained that her kind fed on
the anxiety of children which was why
they lurked under their beds she was
apparently only supposed to remain with
this girl until she was 10 or so but
became attached and decided to stay with
her which was against the rules of her
people and as a result she had been
exiled from her home at this point
Grenda offered to show herself to the
researcher and began to emerge from
under the bed unfortunately as has
become standard when attempting to
document
scp-3887-b all of the recording
equipment malfunctioned and was unable
to record grenda's appearance the
foundation continued you to have
questions about this pair and their
strange relationship and interviewed
scp-3887-a again this time by a Dr
Garden
3887-a told Dr Garden that she had been
sleeping well and had been spending lots
of time talking to the entity under her
bed that led Dr Garden to bring up a
theory about how
scp-3887-b had come to exist the young
woman speculated that Grenda may have
been created from her fears one of her
first memories of being scared was when
she went to an aquarium and a massive
bull shark came close to the glass where
barred its rows and rows of shark teeth
the exact same kind of teeth that Grenda
possessed in fact all the traits Grenda
exhibited like a rat tail seemed to
connect to Childhood fears that she had
experienced
3887-a always felt alone as a little
girl and she believed that she might
have manifested Grenda as a companion
Who was the there exactly when she
needed her to be this raised the
question of whether
scp-3887-b really was the unnatural
entity or if
scp-3887-a is the source of the entities
existence the next interview with
scp-3887-b would raise even more
questions when Dr Garden went to
interview
scp-3887-b it was clear that the entity
was agitated Grenda became hostile as
soon as Dr Garden entered the room
saying she was hungry and didn't want to
answer questions when Dr Garden said
that 3887-a had provided it with socks
The Entity reacted with anger the socks
were just a snack to live it needed fear
3887-b fed off human emotions
specifically paranoia and anxiety
scp-3887-a used to be full of them but
now she was unusually calm in the
facility it was having a bad effect on
her companion when Dr Garden promised to
talk to supervisors the creature became
more agitated and reached out from under
the bed grabbing Dr garden and pulling
her under the bed no one knew what would
happen to Dr Garden under the bed and
scp-3887-a was quickly summoned to try
to calm her companion down but when she
called for grunda there was no response
it was feared that Dr Garden had been
lost to the area under the bed that no
one can access but then 13 minutes later
the doctor suddenly emerged from under
the bed she was bruised soaking wet and
missing articles including shoes socks
and our glasses later interviews with Dr
Garden would give the best picture yet
of where
scp-3887-b comes from Dr Garden
described being pulled under the bed
which then LED somewhere else entirely
she fell for 15 seconds still being held
by scp-3887-b
but when she landed she was alone in a
large cave made of black rock with
purple gems in the walls the cave
contained a waterfall a lake and what
looked like
scp-3887's secret home it was filled
with pictures of the girl she was bonded
to a violin some stuffed animals and
large piles of the girl's socks
scp-3887-b was there in the cave with
her too watching her she would catch
glimpses of the creature her white fangs
and her yellow eyes she was terrified
and ran screaming trying to find any way
out of there as the creature pursued her
she couldn't evade her forever though
and eventually Grenda grabbed Dr Garden
she was lifted into the air as Grenda
bared her shark-like teeth but instead
of eating her the creature instead took
off the doctor's socks and thanked her
before somehow sending her back up into
the darkness she then found herself back
under the bed surround ended by worried
SCP Personnel since then
scp-3887-b has not brought anyone else
into its home it seems feeding on Dr
Garden's fear was enough for the time
being and the situation has remained
stable since the SCP Foundation has been
able to develop relatively simple
containment procedures for the two
entities that make up
scp-3887 as neither is currently hostile
the two are contained within a standard
humanoid containment cell with the bed
at the center
scp-3887-a is given standard amenities a
healthy diet including a vitamin for
some minor health issues and our own
control over the lights in the cell she
has requested and been given a gaming
system for entertainment and up-to-date
entertainment media but was denied
access to the internet a pet cat and
access to the on-site Recreation areas
due to the risk of
scp-3887-b getting loose the facility
does have plans in play place in case
Grenda decides to become hostile again
though while
scp-3887-a normally maintains control of
the lights in her cell the foundation
has a Fail-Safe installed so they can
turn them up at any time since
scp-3887-b reacts negatively to Bright
Light the lights can be used as a
security system to send her retreating
back under the bed until she can be
pacified through other measures while
neither of the
scp-3887 entities appears to be seeking
to escape it is impossible to predict
where and how
3887-b would act if 3887-a was free for
mercel again and whether she would
attempt to harm those she perceives as a
threat to
3887-a as she did in the past so for now
the foundation is focused on keeping
both of them pacified which in the case
of
3887-b means a healthy supply of socks
but there's one other lingering question
the foundation hasn't solved
scp-3887-b referenced being exiled from
its kin for breaking the rules and was
confined to a cave that means there
might be others like Grenda out there
and they may be more aggressive and less
scrupulous than she is while no other
specimens have been found the SCP
Foundation will be keeping a careful eye
on any reports of monsters lurking under
children's beds they might just be
telling the truth an SCP Foundation
researcher is monitoring the salt
content of a large tank filled with
water inside the tank just under the
surface is a huge mass of rusted metal
though few pieces have a couple specks
of their original shiny surface visible
through the dark red exterior the
researcher suddenly looks up from his
task though does anyone else hear that
noise it's a terrible noise like metal
scraping and scratching against each
other but the Heap of metal in the tank
isn't moving still the noises continue
though and the researcher keeps staring
at the unmoving hunk of metal in the
tank all he can think about is diving in
and letting his body become a part of it
keps emerged in a big saltwater tank at
the SCP Foundation is an object but
perhaps a more accurate way to describe
it would be as a machine referred to as
scp-882 the machines containment tank is
required according to containment
procedures to be filled with at least 40
percent pure sea water direct from the
ocean if at any point the rusty surface
of scp-882 begins to show signs of
becoming more like shiny metal than the
percentage of seawater must be raised to
100 percent until the metal is
completely covered in Rust trying to
keep metal rusted that might sound like
a strange concept but you'll see why
it's so necessary soon
scp-882 looks like little more than a
collection of seemingly random pieces of
metal all fused together as if they had
been welded gears cables pulleys screws
and belts all different shapes and sizes
all made of different Metals all of
these various components do not appear
to be uniform or have been made to fit
each other and are instead all stuck
together in one big unstructured mass of
metal objects but scp-882 wasn't built
to be like this instead this seems to be
the result of one of
scp-882's latent anomalous properties
the absorption of metal any metal that
comes into contact with scp-882 will
become permanently attached to it and
after a few days will be a new part of
scp-882 that means that any metal that
touches that new piece will also become
a part of scp-882 and on and on because
of this strange property absolutely no
metal is allowed to be brought near
scp-882 and only organic materials are
permitted to come into direct contact
with it that that includes using
non-metal alternatives to keep the
machine securely contained
scp-882 is suspended in its salt water
tank by organic cotton fiber lines which
also require changing on a daily basis
any and all researchers that the SCP
Foundation has interacting with the
metallic Mass are required to wear thick
cotton gloves at all times you might
think that this sounds pretty easy to
contain just don't let it touch metal no
problem organic materials only no
removal rust aloud no sweat the
foundation staff working with 882
probably felt the same way until they
started hearing
scp-882 make noise while scp-882 is
usually silent Personnel that spend an
extended period of time close to the
machine have reported intense grinding
or clicking noises coming from somewhere
in the mess of metal components while
they start out low and are almost
unnoticeable these sounds get gradually
louder until eventually they be come
completely unbearable for human beings
to withstand so then why don't these
sounds show up on audio recordings
because the grinding or clicking noises
from
scp-882-r and actually extreme auditory
hallucinations but even though they
aren't real these sounds are more than
capable of driving anyone who hears them
into a state of psychosis and here's
where things get tricky the only way to
make the noises stop is to offer scp-882
more metal as mentioned any object that
is made of any type of metal that comes
into contact with the machine becomes a
part of its mass allowing new objects to
become fused to the surface of scp-882
will cause the grinding noises to
subside but will increase
scp-882's Mass permanently if the noises
aren't stopped though then the mental
state of those afflicted by them only
grows worse and some victims of
scp-882's auditory hallucinations have
gone so far as to throw themselves
ourselves into the tank containing it
where they were killed almost
immediately their bodies crushed to
death by anomalous forces and becoming
unrecoverable from the tangle of gears
and random metal objects the SCP
Foundation now requires any of its
Personnel that work directly with
scp-882 to report any instances of noise
coming from the machine additionally
whoever reports hearing strange sounds
in the vicinity of scp-882 must turn
themselves in for a full psychological
evaluation depending on the results the
researcher will either be free to return
to their work or will face containment
themselves at an undisclosed Foundation
facility the surface of scp-882 exhibits
an extreme resistance to damage
according to the foundation's testing
the metal structure has a tensile
strength and toughness stronger than
aircraft-grade titanium alloy despite
this the machine still seems to be
constructed of weaker metals like tin
iron gold and many others still yet to
be identified it takes extreme heat and
several hours of exposure at that to cut
even the smallest portion of metal from
the main bulk of scp-882 but where did
it come from the SCP Foundation First
recovered scp-882 near an island
commonly on the northeast coast of banks
Island one of the larger islands in the
Canadian Arctic archipelago strangely
not a single scrap of metal not even
underground metallic ore was found
within a one mile radius of where the
machine was discovered stranger still
the small town located nearby seemed to
be abandoned with signs that it had been
devoid of any human life for quite a
number of years the collection of fused
metal components later designated
scp-882 was found submerged in seawater
the machine was coated in Rust and the
foundation has chosen to keep it in the
same Rusty state it has been kept in
since its containment why because when
Foundation Personnel first attempted to
remove
scp-882 from the water and the rust
began to flake away from scp-882's metal
surface its gears and cogs started to
turn Foundation Personnel on site were
unsure of what the machine's purpose was
but wanted to Halt it in case it proved
deadly a number of ill-fated attempts at
containment occurred soon after with any
person getting too close to scp-882
finding themselves pulled into its mass
and crushed to death between turning
cogs after multiple accidents that
resulted in the demise of foundation
Personnel Dr Charles gears authorized
the use of
scp-2519 to help stop the movement of
scp-882's Gears
scp-2519 is an audio file titled Babylon
mp3 which features the song By the
Waters of Babylon by Philip Hayes and
texts from the biblical Psalm 137
playing this file can cause malfunctions
to occur in various electronic and
Mechanical Devices Norm reducing the
speed at which they can operate or
causing a complete cessation of a
machine's function in scp-882's case the
sound of Babylon mp3 successfully slowed
The Machine's moving Parts allowing
Foundation Personnel to safely get
closer to it teams then cut the massive
metal down to a more manageable size
with extreme heat and it was finally
contained however another question
arises surely if scp-882 is a machine
then it must have a purpose right and
perhaps more importantly what is its
connection to the infamous machine
loving group of Interest the Church of
the broken God both of these questions
might just have one easy answer to put
it plain and simple
scp-882 may just be the heart of the
broken God the Church of the broken God
is a religious organization that the SCP
Foundation has had a number of
encounters with over the years members
of the church share in the belief that
life specific typically biological
flesh-based life is inherently wrong
even evil this group worships
mechanization the process of making
something or someone more mechanical in
nature according to the beliefs of the
church there were two gods yaldaboth and
McCain who created Humanity together
yaldabath was the god of Flesh and
animal Instinct granting humans their
bodies while meccane the got a machine
and intellect bless man with the power
of free thought as humankind developed
and its civilization began building
machines yaldaboff became enraged that
they were ignoring the instincts she had
bestowed upon them she endeavored to
destroy the creations of man in an
attempt to revert them to the animals
she had intended to be as Legend goes
McCain acted as Humanity's Savior and
intervened to stop yaldabov they got a
machine shattered himself transforming
his body into a number of pieces to form
a cage for his fellow God fragments of
mechan rained down on planet Earth Earth
fragments that the Church of the broken
God believes it is their duty to recover
however a number of these pieces are
cataloged to scps that the foundation is
either aware of or has in containment
they are scp-882 or is broken heart to
the church
scp-271 his broken gift
scp-813 his Broken Eyes
scp-1139 has broken tongue
scp-635 has broken mind and finally his
broken blood which refers to
scp-217 often using anomalous technology
members of the Church of the broken God
intend to uncover or steal these various
components the church's ultimate goal is
to bring the correct pieces together and
completely restore mechanes form it is
their hope that he will guide them to
intellectual Enlightenment and bless
them with new mechanical forms so that
they can discard their current Flesh and
Blood bodies however the foundation and
the church are certainly not the only
groups to have a fascination with
scp-882 near the banks Island site where
the machine was first discovered
Foundation Personnel encountered a man
the sole survivor of the nearby town
this individual by the name of Richard
Wright was apprehended and brought in
for questioning with Dr gears during
their interview Richard revealed a
number of details about the townsfolk
who had first uncovered
scp-882 and what ultimately became of
them according to his account the
community formed a cult around
scp-882 after a man named Alan found it
the machine's Parts had begun to turn
and move but with no clear indication as
to what was powering it soon a local
priest Father Pat also took an interest
in scp-882 both he and Alan seemed to
share the belief that the machine had
been built by God for a higher purpose
and encouraged residents of the nearby
town to come and offer metal to it
Richard explained that the locals were
plagued by the auditory hallucinations
tip typical of long-term exposure to
scp-882 kept awake at all hours of the
Night by clanking grinding and the
screaming of metal before long Richard
noticed more and more metal items being
fed to the machine with many local
residents content to just sit and stare
at the mass he also noticed that Father
Pat and Alan both seem to be acting
strangely around the machine insisting
that all the metal that had been added
to it still wasn't enough then one night
during a communion before
scp-882 Father Pat took a pair of pliers
and began tearing out townspeople's
metal fillings Richard watched in horror
as the priest wrenched teeth from the
mouths of ordinary people and threw them
into
scp-882 but still claiming it wasn't
enough then he turned on Allen accusing
him of hiding metal from the great
machine inside his body the townsfolk
turned on Alan the first one to find
scp-882 and threw him and his metal hip
into the machine his body breaking under
its moving Parts luckily scp-882 remains
contained at least for now until the
members of the Church of the broken God
find a way to reunite the heart of their
god with the other pieces of its
scattered body and meccane can Rise
Again an outcome that his worshipers are
eager to bring to fruition sooner rather
than later it was the summer of 2012 in
Damascus and for the people of Syria it
certainly seemed like all the
predictions about the end of the world
were coming true the Syrian Civil War
was raging between multiple Rebel groups
and the dictator Bashar al-assad whose
government was shelling its own people
as well as using chemical weapons and
brutal campaigns of violence across the
country in hopes of quelling the
Rebellion little did they know admits to
all this pain and bloodshed something
even more dangerous was brewing an
anomalous phenomenon in the sunny Plains
north of that may pose a threat to all
of humanity someday a threat known to
the SCP Foundation as
scp-3989 the bone Orchard this temporal
and spatial anomaly was discovered a few
years earlier in 2009 before the Syrian
Civil War even officially began it's
strange for a highly dangerous
ketterclass anomaly to be discovered
under such seemingly mundane
circumstances the SCP Foundation first
became aware of
scp-3989 after a small Olive Orchard
owner sold a strangely high amount of
Olives that shouldn't have been possible
when compared to his reported number of
Olea europea olive trees field agents
were dispatched to question the owner
about his sudden success but he was
resistant to questioning the agents
began a covert surveillance operation to
figure out what was actually going on
here at which point they discovered a
considerable spatial anomaly the olive
Orchard was Far bigger on the inside the
property was seized by the foundation
for containment the owner had no real
knowledge of the spatial anomaly it's
likely he just decided not to look a
gift horse in the mouth while making
money hand over fist from the extra
olives he sold the owner was given him
knee sticks and a new life as the
foundation began to study this anomaly
which was now labeled
scp-3989 to this day no researcher has
been able to figure out the origin of
3989's anomalous qualities it was first
given a euclid-class designation and
cordon off from the public with a simple
chain-link fence while Foundation
investigations were underway on the
inside on a map the plot of land the
olive Farm should occupy is about five
square acres but this plot contains an
unseen portal to a pocket Dimension
within its 12 meter active Zone which
doesn't follow the same spatial laws
that our reality does this subdimension
known as
scp-3989-a is a hotbed of fascinating
anomalous activity upon discovery of
this Hot Zone the foundation established
the nearby area 126 as a research center
and a makeshift containment facility for
any anomalous entities captured from
scp-3989-a it seemed like the foundation
really had a handle on this situation
but they were blissfully unaware of the
true Horrors lurking with an
scp-3989-a but they'd soon find out in
the most horrifying way possible Dr
farakazelli was assigned to head the
research into the anomalous Zone within
3989 and naturally he began organizing
fact-finding Expeditions Into the Heart
of the affected area the first guinea
pig to head into The Hot Zone was former
Foundation agent Hosea Herrick who'd
been demoted to the lowly d-class
position of
d-126-15 due to failures on a previous
Mission with a remote link to Dr gazelli
Herrick was forced to venture into the
active anomalous Zone to collect footage
and samples of the Flora and Fauna
within the first thing Herrick noticed
on his expedition was the strange
quality of the olive trees within the
active Zone The Bark was a stark white
and the leaves a bloody red up close her
could see that the Trunks and branches
of the trees had undergone a process
known as ossification where the material
slowly becomes bone or bone-like tissue
hence the anomaly's creepy name the bone
Orchard these ossified trees became
known as
scp-3989-1 Herrick also made another
Discovery all over the trees and ground
were worm-like creatures that looked
like long maggots that the foundation
dubbed
scp-3989-1a agent Herrick then noticed
something was off about the leaves of
the ossified trees they were beating he
looked closer and they appeared to be
heart tissue filled with pumping veins
Dr gazelli ordered Herrick to take a
branch for testing and when he did the
tree began to bleed when he looked down
he saw that the worm-like creatures that
covered the ground were now crawling up
his legs ignoring orders from Dr gazelli
Herrick fled from the active Zone in
Terror as he left Dr gazelli caught
something in the corner of herrick's
body cam footage a long white hind limb
disappearing behind a tree back in our
normal Dimension tests on the sample
hair collected yielded more upsetting
discoveries genetically the trees were
identical to humans the trunks were
human bone and the leaves really were
made of human heart tissue fascinated
and just a little bit horrified Dr
gazelle authorized further Expeditions
into
3989-a this time though agent Herrick
would be accompanied by another d-class
and both would be armed with handguns
and protective body armor as it would
turn out this Expedition would be even
more horrifying than the first as the 2D
classes explored the active zones to
collect further samples they found that
the worms were responsible for the
ossification of the otherwise
non-anomalous olive tree they consume
the wood little by little and deposited
human bone matter in return Herrick and
His companion also noticed that these
trees were beginning to bear fruit Dr
gazelli ordered Herrick to collect some
of this fruit for testing but when they
attempted to remove the fruit it burst
releasing more worm creatures it seemed
that the converted trees acted as
incubators for their egg sacs before the
duo could return with the samples they
were able to take the creature that had
been spotted on herrick's body cam
during the first mission finally
appeared it was huge with long white
Limbs and no facial features except for
a huge mouth it grabbed herrick's
companion and literally ate the top half
of his body in a single bite before
dropping his legs to the ground this
horrifying Beast and the many others
like it would later be designated as
scp-3989-2a Herrick pulled out his
sidearm and shot the creatures several
times the creature ignored the bullets
though and charged Herrick the feed from
his body cam cut out soon after both men
were declared killed in action and in
recognition of his sacrifice Josiah
Herrick was posthumously reinstated to
his old position in the foundation job
well done agent Dr gazelli meanwhile
prepared for the next mission this time
knowing of the clear dangers present
within the bone Orchard Dr gazelli
recruited the help of MTF Zeta 9 aka the
mole rats three members referred to as
Charlie team were sent into the
anomalous Zone once again remotely
directed by Dr gazelli they were
equipped with experimental ultrasound
technology so they could scan the fruit
of the trees within
3989-a without breaking any and
incurring the wrath of
3989-2a which seemed to act as centuries
for the trees early on in their Journey
they found the body of agent Herrick
crucified against one of the ossified
trees his skin covered in mysterious
symbols that were likely of sarkic or
origin while we don't have time to fully
explore sarcasism that will require a
video explanation all of its own all you
need to know is that it's a dangerous
religious cult that worships flesh and
disease and has close ties to similar
dangerous anomalies like scp-610 also
known as the flesh that hates people
familiar with that SCP will note eerily
strange similarities to some of the
things the mole rats were about to
encounter as Charlie team explored they
saw a huge number of 3989 2a's observing
them with eyeless faces from between the
ossified trees they pressed on until
they discovered what seemed to be an
entirely new kind of tree within the
bone Orchard
scp-3989-2 were huge trees made out of
what appears to be enlarged human spines
in place of a trunk the smaller Twigs on
the tree were made from heart and lung
tissue and the whole thing was covered
in what appeared to be human amniotic
sex Charlie team attempted to use their
ultrasound scanners to discover the
contents of these sacks but one of them
exploded in the process releasing an
entirely new variety of monster from the
sax emerged the larval stage of
scp-3989-2b smaller humanoid monsters
with no faces No sensory organs two
pelvises four legs and an exposed spine
suddenly Charlie team could feel a
horrifying psychic presence around them
which one member of the team described
as being like someone grabbing her liver
and giggling in her face as the various
Monsters of the bone Orchard began to
converge on the team the voice of the
sarcic prophet of War and the hunt auruk
begins sounding in their ears he was
beckoning them to join him while Charlie
team fled from the active Zone Dr
gazelli felt increasingly drawn into it
he heard the voice of Uruk and he liked
what he heard little by little the
workers of area 126 were losing their
minds men manipulated by the sarkic
power of the bone orchard right next to
them day after day they were no longer
loyal to the foundation they wanted to
serve their new Dark Masters the fourth
and final expedition was led by Dr
gazelli himself he took a band of loyal
followers and one non-believer on a
quest into the active Zone to find an
orchian Temple they believed was hidden
in the very heart of the bone Orchard
once they were inside gazelle and his
loyalists murdered the non-believer as a
sacrifice to their new master They
carried on until they eventually found
what they were looking for a giant Stone
Temple resembling an Aztec ziggurat
dubbed
scp-3989-4 there they also encountered a
new kind of monster dubbed
scp-3989-3 these beasts were larger than
the others and resembled ancient
warriors they had insect-like
exoskeletal armor horned heads
additional Hind and four limbs an
integrated bladed weapons what Dr
gazelle and his companions thought would
be paradise turned out to be a kind of
hell as they were led into the temple
where temporal and spatial distortions
broke their mind and the multiple highly
aggressive instances of
scp-3989-3-2a and dash 2B broke their
bodies the whole thing had been a
horrifying trap in that moment back at
area 126 another fleshy horrifying tree
sprouted out of the ground in the middle
of the complex monsters that had once
been Dr gazelli and his followers
emerged from its amniotic sacks and all
hell broke loose throughout the complex
soon enough the base was crawling with
monsters from the bone Orchard and staff
who'd become brainwashed circuit
cultists working in service of Uruk
humans were gathered up to be sacrificed
to the ever-growing number of anomalous
trees things came to a head when the
anomaly in area 126 was visited by an
outside agent from the foundation
working on behalf of the Hazardous
Materials containment liaison biological
containment specialist Dr Marshall Grant
and his team arrived at the site and
were horrified to see the sarkic
nightmare that had unfolded they quickly
engaged in a firefight with the
anomalous creatures and sarkic devotees
who'd gained control over area 126. a
number of Dr Grant's team were lost in
the process but thankfully they were
able to eventually regain control of the
base and the anomalous area after this
incident
scp-3989 was upgraded to ketterclass and
given a huge upgrade in security
including four meter high concrete walls
and a platoon-sized regimen of mobile
task force members with heavy Weaponry
the force that took over the minds of
those exposed was designated
scp-3989-5 a force so powerful that
those infected are given the choice to
self-terminate or be contained forever
ever this may seem like a somewhat happy
ending to a grim Tale But one detail
keeps Dr Grant and everyone at the
foundation who is forced to deal with
39.89 awake at night according to all
recent studies into the bone Orchard it
isn't contained at all in fact the
active zone is getting bigger the SCP
Foundation is an organization that
polices the abnormal in all its forms
whether it's a multi-dimensional chaos
God a big scaly monster or a very
effective coffee machine the foundation
takes a pointed interest in pretty much
anything outside the norm so you're
probably wondering what would they want
with Mr Smith a man who is about as
normal and average as could be Mr Smith
was a 47 year old African-American
construction worker with a wife and
daughter he lived a modest but contented
life he had a close circle of friends a
happy family and was well liked among
his co-workers but Mr Smith had no idea
about the anomalous nightmare barreling
down the tracks towards him Mr Smith
wasn't just about to have his life
destroyed by an anomaly he was about to
become one it seemed like a normal day
at work on the construction site when he
received a phone call it was the police
informing him that his wife and young
daughter had been involved in a terrible
car accident while this is anyone's
worst nightmare it was only the start of
the horrifying things that were about to
happen to poor poor Mr Smith that night
when Mr Smith went to sleep he fell
victim to a strange phenomenon he
started to disappear while it would be
easy to write off as the result of
mental illness like a kind of
stressed-induced mental breakdown Mr
Smith wasn't the only one who noticed or
rather didn't notice his co-workers
would slowly begin to forget details
about him even obvious things that you
could glean from simply looking at a
person like clothes height or skin color
it seemed that little by little ever
since his family died Mr Smith was
becoming an unperson this led to
increasing levels of fear paranoia and
distress as people whom he'd thought of
as his closest friends could barely
recognize him anymore thankfully Mr
Smith wasn't just going to slip into
non-existence without a fight he
realized early on that his new
conditions seemed to abide by certain
rules the effects got worse in the night
when he was alone but seemed to lessen
somewhat during the day when he was
interacting with people it seemed that
he disappeared just that little bit more
whenever he wasn't being interacted with
and perhaps he hadn't developed this
condition upon the death of his wife and
child maybe he'd had it for a while but
it was the constant presence of his
family that kept the effects from
worsening but now that he'd properly
identified the problem Mr Smith could
begin devising some solutions if nobody
else was there to interact with him and
night he'd keep his position in reality
stable by interacting with himself Mr
Smith would repeat his own name to
himself regularly reaffirming his
existence to himself he'd often check
his own pulse to feel the rhythm of his
heartbeat he'd write detailed
descriptions of himself either on his
own body or a surrounding surface and in
one particular stroke of Genius he
devised a method of recording his own
voice talking to himself and playing it
back while he was asleep to Stave off
reality Decay during the day while at
work or just existing socially in the
world you do everything he could to
constantly interact with people that way
they could keep reaffirming his presence
and therefore continuing his existence
the symptoms of Mr Smith's condition are
somewhat similar to a rare mental
illness known as the kotard delusion in
which a patient believes they are dead
dying or don't even exist except in Mr
Smith's unfortunate case the delusion is
becoming a reality and this was a
reality that Mr Smith could only hold
off for so long little by little the
coping mechanisms he'd built to manage
his new life began to collapse people in
his inner circle truly began to forget
him his company no longer recognized him
as an employee to the people who barely
knew him he was little more than a ghost
a kind of palpable absence this was the
point when the SCP Foundation finally
got involved they swooped in and
apprehended Mr Smith redesignating him
as
scp-1467 it was one of the rare
occasions that the foundation didn't
need to apply any amnestic treatment to
bystanders because due to the nature of
Mr Smith's anomalous activity almost
everyone who knew him was already in the
process of forgetting him when the
foundation interviewed a man that Mr
Smith referred to as a close friend he
couldn't even recall Mr Smith's basic
physical trait with any reliability
because of Mr Smith's condition the
foundation had real difficulty verifying
elements of his backstory Mr Smith told
the foundation researchers everything
about himself about his family and his
life before but field agents were
stumped whenever they tried to follow up
on the information first there were
issues with the existence and fate of
his supposed wife and child no records
were ever found of either of these
people existing and there was no
existing documentation to prove that Mr
Smith was ever married the foundation
also looked into the deaths of Mrs Smith
and her child there were no records of a
car crash in the area that Mr Smith
directed them to but that's not all
there were also no death records nor any
Graves ever found the construction
company that Mr Smith claimed to work
for had no records of his employment
they couldn't find any of Mr Smith's
supposed extended family either the only
proof that he had ever existed was his
physical body locked in a foundation
humanoid containment cell and Mr Smith's
own words if you think this sounds like
a living nightmare then Mr Smith would
wholeheartedly agree with you the
effects of his anomalous nature
traumatized Mr Smith he was diagnosed by
Foundation therapists as suffering from
bipolar depression as well as chronic
sleep deprivation though if you
disappeared a little more every time you
slept you'd probably lose a lot of sleep
too the unpredictable nature of Mr
Smith's anomalous traits could have
equally unpredictable effects on the
nature of his containment so he was
classified as Euclid Mr Smith is one of
the few anomalies that is referred to by
his real name at least to his face when
referred to as
scp-1467 Mr Smith enters a state of rage
and panic and this mistake has caused
several injuries for foundation
Personnel during attempts to restrain
him after using his SCP number around
him Mr Smith is contained in a foam
padded cell to prevent self-destructive
Behavior along with three audio
recording devices though these were
installed at his own request in order to
continue his habit of recording his own
voice to play back to himself while
asleep this served the dual purpose of
not only mitigating his fading from
reality but also keeping him calm and
docile during containment and these
devices are kept in good working order
in order to avoid creating hostility
between Mr Smith and Foundation staff
while it may seem that the anomalous
effects of Mr Smith purely serve to
create a personal hell for him and him
alone the foundation wasn't so sure the
fact no records could be found of his
wife daughter or extended family was
concerning it raised one frightening
question are the effects of Mr Smith's
condition contagious if so he could be
putting a lot of people in grave danger
Foundation scientists headed by senior
researcher Dr Thorne devised a series of
experiments to better understand Mr
Smith's mysterious condition there were
22 experiments in total but things began
to get interesting at around experiment
16. for this experiment Mr Smith was
forcibly restrained and brought into a
research chamber with research
assistants Rainier and Dieter they were
told to Simply observe Mr Smith without
interacting with him and record what
happened in the process while Dr Thorne
supervised at 10 minutes and 12 seconds
the researchers were unable to recognize
the subject as Mr Smith at 14 minutes
and 32 seconds they were unable to
recognize the clothes of Mr Smith less
than 10 minutes later they were unable
to identify his Reigns five minutes
after that they couldn't identify what
Mr Smith was currently doing 10 minutes
later they couldn't even identify how Mr
Smith was sitting at almost 40 minutes
the research assistants weren't able to
identify anything of Mr Smith save for
the fact that there was some kind of
humanoid creature are in the room at
this point research assistant theater
started a recording instructing Mr Smith
to describe himself on record as this
happened Smith returned to a describable
State curled up in a fetal position on
the floor there was no sign of the
restraints or the chair in which Smith
had been placed subsequent tests showed
similar results with minor variations in
timing just by being in physical contact
with Mr Smith the chair and the
restraints had literally faded out of
existence evidence was really pointing
towards Mr Smith's anomalous effects
being potentially detrimental to the
people and objects around him but the
experiments continued they had to know
more before there was nothing left to
know the next series of experiments were
performed with d-classes and led Dr
Thorne and his team of researchers to a
number of frightening conclusions 2D
classes locked in with Mr Smith as he
slipped out of existence began
experiencing extreme states of Terror
and distress even when they could no
longer see him they could still feel the
presence of an entity in the room when
the 2D classes tried to escape one of
them was almost mistaken from Mr Smith
himself he too was now starting to slip
out of existence both d-classes were
summarily terminated and Dr Thorne began
to wonder whether Mr Smith's condition
was contagious or if he was instead
somehow able to lash out at others in
his vicinity in a more localized fashion
only two other experiments were ever
performed on Mr Smith before further
experimentation into his case was
permanently suspended in the first a
non-violent d-class was placed in Mr
Smith's cell and ordered to ignore him
Mr Smith didn't take this well he began
attacking the d-class who fought back
breaking Mr Smith's nose ironically this
physical attack was actually beneficial
to Mr Smith as the violence helped
ground him in reality and secured his
existence just that little bit more in
the final experiment Mr Smith was given
a cellmate a female d-class who was
allowed to acknowledge Him the two
appeared to become close and their time
helped Stave off Mr Smith's fading just
a little bit longer it's unknown if she
contracted his fading condition or
somehow was able to escape but one day
while Mr Smith slept she simply
disappeared Mr Smith fell into a state
of almost catatonic silence soon after
he began to speak again only to repeat I
don't want to go again and again and
again experiments concluded for good not
long after because of his delicate
mental state Mr Smith is allowed a visit
from a therapist every week and before
any future experiments are performed on
Mr Smith researchers are required to
seek permission from his active
therapist because of his effects on the
minds of people aware of him Foundation
protocol is to terminate Mr Smith
immediately if he ever breaches
containment the site director has also
appended a memo to Smith's file
instructing Personnel to refer to to Mr
Smith as
scp-1467 whenever he's out of your shot
doing otherwise will incur severe
punishments records on Mr Smith are
backed up in six separate copies and
stored in different locations in hopes
that this will prevent the information
from decaying like Mr Smith's existence
Mr Smith's story is one of pain tragedy
and existential horror there's no
shortage of scps that can cause XK Class
end of the world scenarios but sometimes
the terror of these anomalies pales in
comparison to scps that can bring one
person's World crashing down around them
according to all the SCP Foundation
studies it's likely that Mr Smith will
disappear sometime soon regardless of
their intervention everyone in the
Sleepy Mountain Town had heard stories
about the abandoned mall and the
malevolent creature that lurked in the
wreckage there there had been enough
missing persons cases
lost children teenagers sneaking out to
explore and never returning home Urban
explorers who stumbled out of the
darkness disheveled and traumatized with
an eyewitness account no one wanted to
believe there wasn't anyone left in the
surrounding area willing to set foot in
that cursed place but that didn't stop
opportunistic out of counters from
paying the occasional visit especially
if they felt like there was money to be
made in those crumbling corporate walls
Grant and Jason the hosts of
up-and-coming investigative reality show
ghostly happenings were two such
visitors when they heard the rumors
about an abandoned Mall haunted by some
sort of dark presence blame for The
Disappearance of local children they
packed up their van picked up their
underpaid cameraman Derek and headed
straight for the infamous building are
you sure we're allowed to be here Derek
asked shakely as he began filming nope
Grant answered cheerfully that's part of
the fun Jason laughed look man this
place has been left to rot by the city
no one cares if we're shooting some
footage besides worrying less about the
cops and more about the ghosts of them
all grand grand
not funny Derek crumbled come on serious
faces were rolling Jason nudged his
co-host and the two snapped into their
on-camera personalities once a bustling
Center of suburban American life this
shopping mall has transformed into a den
of Terror Grant's voice dropped into a
lower register his expression intense
local swap stories of something inhuman
that calls this place home something
that doesn't take kindly to trespassers
Jason added a ghost a demon just an
urban legend that's what we're here to
find out Grant pulled out an EMF reader
which began beeping as he turned it on
ah there seems to be a lot of activity
in here already I'm picking up something
don't know if you folks at home can see
this put the meters going crazy Jason
exclaimed it was a fake meter of course
one that they rigged up to beep and
react when Grant press certain hidden
buttons but the audience didn't need to
know that they were tuning in for story
for spectacle not for the truth if they
wanted that they could flip over to the
nature Channel and watch some lions
chasing a gazelle on this show they were
chasing pure entertainment they
continued deeper into the building
taking in the massive echoey space the
dusty storefronts the beams of rotten
Woods strewn across the ground the rats
that skittered across the floor it was
the perfect creepy atmosphere maybe a
little too perfect a little too creepy
what was that Derek practically jumped
out of his skin spinning around to look
at something behind him hey stay on us
Grant snapped I saw something moving
back there Derek insisted it was a rat
Jason rolled his eyes there are tons of
them in here Derek shook his head no it
wasn't a rat it was way too big okay a
raccoon man come on get it together
we've been in way worse locations than
this remember that old tuberculosis
Hospital Grant shuttered God man that
was scary this is nothing well not
nothing Jason elbowed his partner I did
a good job scouting this place right
grant was about to answer when his foot
bumped something on the ground he looked
down and saw a Polaroid camera next to a
long empty water bottle and a small
backpack oh man get a shot of this Derek
obliged while Jason took a closer look
this must have belonged to one of the
Urban Explorer types who came in here he
unzipped the backpack rummaging around
hey look photos tons of them he dumped
the pictures out onto the ground think
he got some Spirit photography done
before he bit the dust I might as well
see Grant joined Jason on the ground
sifting through the photos as Derek
watched anxiously barring boring dear
dog Sunset oh wait a minute he stopped
holding up one specific Polaroid this is
the money shot right here Derek zoom in
on this all three men looked at the
picture illuminated by the camera's
light it showed a tall long limbed pale
creature vaguely humanoid in shape but
at the same time distinctly not quite
human its mouth was stretched wide in a
wordless screech its eyes bloodshot and
wild it's long tapered fingers were
reaching towards the camera damn that's
spooky Jason laughed a bit of
nervousness creeping into his voice how
do you think he set this up Grant asked
what if it's real Derek swallowed the
lump in his throat don't be an idiot
Grant scoffed but then from the outside
not 100 feet away they heard a scream
ears splittingly loud filled with rage
pain and animalistic Instinct it was
like nothing any of them had ever heard
before the scream was followed by the
sound of splitting wood branches
crashing to the ground and horrifyingly
the sound of something breaking down a
nearby wall what did you do Jason backed
away from the sound me you open the
backpack Grant shot back guys I think we
need to get out of here Derek watched in
wide-eyed Terror as two pale hands
ripped a hole in the wall in front of
them making an opening for that pale
hairless head from the photograph to
poke through all three men prepared to
make a break for it and run for their
lives but as soon as the creature saw
them it was already too late with
another scream scp-096 sprinted toward
them grabbing each man and throwing them
to the ground the camera shattered into
pieces from the impact and Derek skidded
painfully across the ground as he rolled
onto his side to try and push back up to
his feet he caught a glimpse of the
monster opening its mouth impossibly
wide and descending on his bosses he
really didn't want to focus on what
happened next but suffice to say there
was nothing of them left afterwards
Derek tried his best to escape but he
was no match for the brute strength and
speed of scp-096 from the moment he saw
its face his fate was sealed there was
no Escape soon the beeping EMF meter the
scattered photographs and the broken
pieces of the camera were the only thing
left of the crew from ghostly happenings
their devoted fans would never get
another episode but at least one being
in the abandoned Mall could could rest
easy now
scp-096 was safe again no one was living
who had seen its face it slowly crawled
back to the hole it had made in the wall
ready to return to the forest and climb
back up the mountain there could curl up
beneath a tree and stay there for as
long as it wanted but as scp-096 reached
the hole in the wall where it had once
been able to see night sky stars and the
trees in the distance there was only
Blackness it was as if something dark
was stretching over the opening blocking
the outside world from view 096 reached
out a hand to push the blockage out of
the way but whatever it was slithered
away from the touch faster than the pale
hand could move the wriggling darkness
crept back into the building weaving in
and out of the shadows as scp-096
watched it curiously whatever it was it
hadn't looked at the creature's face yet
it wasn't sure if this thing even had
eyes but then stretching out of the
darkness an interview was a garish face
with wide white eyes with massive pupils
a round nose and a wide wide mouth
stretched into a toothy Grimace that
might have once looked like a smile this
was the creature that had made the mall
its home the apex predator of this
biosphere and it was staring directly at
scp-096's face its face with the shriek
096 flew into a Primal Rage clawing at
the cat-like creature but before 096
could reach it the thing was gone where
was it where did it go 096 roared
tearing at the floor ripping up the tile
and gouging long deep scratches in the
concrete beneath a sound in the distance
Drew 096's attention and it bolted in
the direction of the noise swinging at
any obstacle in its path as it went it
wrote down a banner advertising free
frozen yogurt samples crushed an empty
cell phone kiosk and threw a gumball
machine to the floor with a crash it
would rip the entire Mall apart if it
had to if that was what it took to
destroy the being that I'd caught a
glimpse of its face and disappeared then
096 could see it that face that
wide-eyed grinning face it sprinted
toward the face as fast as it could the
cartoon cat was looking at 096 not from
a place in the room but from behind the
screen of a television in the
electronics store window somehow defying
the laws of physics and reality it had
made its way into the TV 096 didn't
pause to ponder the logic of this there
was no room for critical thought there
was only the need to shred to consume to
destroy it burst through the window
sending shards of glass in every
direction and reared back to attack the
screen it was so focused on its singular
task that it didn't notice the long
black arms snaking across the floor
winding around its feet all of a sudden
096 lost its balance as its legs were
pulled right out from under it those
stretchy arms dragging it into the TV
screen itself when 096 regained
Consciousness it was in a place it did
not recognize gone was the inside of
them all or the familiar forest and
mountains outside instead scp-096 was in
some sort of hand-drawn World a massive
house with a hallway that seemed to go
on forever lined with infinite doors
leading to who knew where the floor
tipped and tilted at odd angles and the
geometry made no three-dimensional sense
it was dizzying and deeply off-putting
scp-096 had no frame of reference to
compare it to but a human witness might
have noticed that this place looked like
something out of an old cartoon from the
days of Steamboat Willie and the like
scp-096 did not think such a thing it
only knew that it was in an unfamiliar
Place one that fell threatening though
there were no visible threats and it
knew that it still hadn't gotten its
hands on the creature that had seen its
face all along the walls between each
door there were clocks in the shape of
that horrible cat eyes ticking back and
forth with each second wide smile
mocking scp-096 as if to say try and
find me
scp-096 would not be discouraged there
was no room in its mind for that sort of
thing it was only the singular goal of
finding the cartoon cat and tearing it
limb from rubber hose limb psychological
warfare would have no effect still
cartoon cat would give it his best shot
this was his world and he could do
whatever he wanted here cartoon cat
poked his head out through a random
doorway waving to 096 with one of his
puffy white gloved hands as 096 wailed
and began to give Chase cartoon cats
slammed the door shut only to open
another door down the hall and poke his
head head out of that one he did the
same trick over and over jerking scp-096
around from end to end of the ever
expanding animated hallway after some
time passed however it appeared as cp096
was not going to get tired and was not
going to give up hope of catching its
prey it was time to end this cartoon cat
wrapped one long arm around
scp-096's neck restraining it against
the wall and began to squeeze Tighter
and Tighter but nothing happened
scp-096 did not collapse did not react
at all except to tear out the arm around
its neck until it broke free then it
returned to the Relentless Pursuit
tearing door frames apart pulling up
floorboards punching through walls every
time it dealt damage to the environment
the space filled itself back in an
unseen pen scribbling in the gaps in the
floorboards sealing up the holes and the
walls two powerful beings going back and
forth locked in a seemingly equal
matched battle cartoon cat tried to
destroy scp-096 in a myriad of ways he
tried to rip the Beast apart to snap its
neck to do any manner of unspeakable
violent acts it had done before with
great sadistic Glee but this pale
Abomination would not fold would not
break this wasn't going to be any fun if
there was no ending and if 096 kept
destroying one of cartoon cat's favorite
pocket worlds that was quite enough
cartoon cat grabbed hold of 096's arms
and legs the creature thrashing
viciously as he did so and threw it into
the blank space just beyond the
Illustrated world back in the mall
scp-096 crashed back to Earth was about
to resume its search for cartoon cat
when suddenly a bright light illuminated
its face a police officer stood a few
feet away holding a flashlight excuse me
you can't be in here your trespassing
the officer started to warn but his
words were interrupted when 096 began to
scream soon he would be screaming too it
had been the same nightmare for weeks
now but always Fading Into Echoes as he
awoke not tonight though tonight he was
able to see more to hold on to the
details of his Dark Twisted dream and
the warning it contained Dr Steven
strange had once been an accomplished
surgeon yet fate had destined him to
become the sorcerer Supreme of Earth
after a car accident claimed the use of
his hands now strange was a protector of
his world and countless others in the
vast expanse of the Multiverse a master
of the Mystic Arts wielding his skills
in sorcery and Arcane artifacts to
defend against malevolent otherworldly
threats but even he had never seen
anything like this nightmare before on
the night where the details of the dream
felt easier to keep a hold on a sleeping
Steven was shown all manner of Horrors
the world he had devoted himself to
protecting was crumbling burn
all around was death and suffering the
air shrill with the screams of tortured
innocent souls to make matters worse
within the dream strange could feel the
same suffering reaching out crossing the
boundaries between realities it wasn't
just his world he saw dying it was all
of them every corner of the Multiverse
falling it turned his stomach it all
felt so real not just an anxious
unconscious fantasy of something he
feared might happen this was a warning
of something that would come to pass the
dread felt by The Sorcerer's Supreme
only got worse as he witnessed a
familiar figure injured and broken
crawling free of the rubble of a
destroyed City the flickering light of
endless fires doing little to mask the
man's wounds instantly Doctor Strange
recognized the wounded figure from the
distinctive flared cloak he wore to his
goatee and dark hair graying at the
temples it was him or rather another
version of him from a different reality
within the Multiverse
help the other strange said weakly
instantly Stephen knelt to help his
interdimensional doppelganger up what
happened here he asked concerned at the
vision of Destruction all around I
couldn't stop it the messenger strange
replied and labored breaths he was
wounded fatally barely holding on slow
down breathe Doctor Strange calmly
instructed his other self still
retaining a bedside manner from his days
as a surgeon this Vision I take it
you're trying to warn me of something
yes the dying sorcerer replied I cast a
spell that should reach you in your
sleep although sending a message across
the multiverses
he paused to wince in pain feeling his
already fading strength dwindling
further it takes a lot more than I have
left it's all right strange assured him
I can hear you I'm listening I only wish
I could do more for you it's all right
his very enforced a weak Smile by the
time this message reaches you I'll
already have been dead but you need to
be warned what happened here strange
urged it's not what has happened it's
what's coming it had to be us of course
it did the other's breaths started
slowing I tried everything I really did
but he I've never felt power like it
just tell me who Stephen shouted where
his other self was fading fast desperate
to hear the full warning before the
dream ended already Dr Strange's mind
was racing with potential candidates who
could have been responsible he knew of a
plethora of deities and destructive
creatures capable of launching attacks
on his home universe and many of whom
had time and time again there were the
likes of nightmare and Shuma glass and
of course his arch nemesis dormammu an
entity who had long desired total
control over this plane of existence
Stephen's Earth inhabited but not one of
them had the power to subjugate the
entire Multiverse in one Fell Swoop
please messenger strange rasped leading
up to Steven's ear don't make the same
mistake I did beware the Scarlet gang he
collapsed his breathing stopped as
Doctor Strange looked at the horrific
side of a man almost identical to him
dying having failed to prevent the chaos
that was now consuming everything the
sorcerer Supreme had an encyclopedic
knowledge of the Mystic Arts and all
kinds of occult beings that he had never
heard of the Scarlet King as he woke in
a cold sweat still feeling the same
dread he felt in the dream Doctor
Strange could remember the warning from
his other multiversal self it had to be
him he had to stop the Scarlet King The
Scarlet who repeated Wong Steven's
trusted friend and confident an expert
in both and martial arts as well as an
accomplished scholar Scarlet King the
other me was adamant that this thing had
to be stopped by another version of me
Doctor Strange explained having woken up
flustered with growing concern over his
vision Stephen had spent the whole
morning in the library the sanctum
sanctorium had long been Strange's home
and base of operations since he had
inherited the title of sorcerer's
Supreme from the ancient one
additionally the magical building in the
heart of New York's Greenwich Village
also possessed a sprawling Library
filled with tomes that contained what
was thought to be the sum total of all
occult knowledge his books were filled
with useful information on spells other
planes of existence even detailing
accounts of threats Steven had already
faced like dormammu and yet there was no
mention of any Scarlet King I don't
understand it my other selfie mentioned
it specifically by name but I can't find
a single reference to it in any texts
strange side and frustration the book of
kaglistro nothing no mention of a
Scarlet King strange Wong
what no I mean it's unusual you found
nothing his friend answered trying to
hide a smile at catching Steven in a
joke perhaps the book of vishanti holds
more answers it contains all the
knowledge the great sorcerer agamoto
collected on the Mystic nope already
tried that doctor strange interrupted I
consulted our copy on the dark hole too
while I was at it you did what Wong
exclaimed ever concerned by Steven's
arrogant and Reckless Behavior the dark
hold was a dangerous Tome a book of
spells used only for Pure Evil written
by an elder god named kython even though
the original true darkhold Was Out Of
Reach the knowledge contained within the
copy Stephen possessed was still
perilous to be exposed to ah relax
strange replied in a rather blase manner
still absent-mindedly flicking through
the pages of another book the Codex
Imperium damn it I need to know what it
is I'm up against he yelled in
frustration Wong you didn't see what I
saw in that dream it was chaos
destruction unlike anything I've ever
felt before I understand Stephen his
fellow sorcerer answered and as sorcerer
Supreme you hold a duty to protect this
reality from those that would seek to
threaten its safety but this is
dangerous a being we know nothing about
is rare perhaps consider if there's a
reason why we know nothing of this
Scarlet King there is some knowledge
that is not meant to be uncovered
knowledge is power old friend Doctor
Strange retorted if I'm gonna do my duty
to protect our reality I need to know
anything that will give me an edge I'll
be in my study with that the sorcerer
Supreme Strode off to a private corner
of the sanctum he spent the next few
Restless hours using his Mastery of the
occult to peer into the future
understanding the mystical mechanics of
time in the way he did when Steven was
aware that there was no singular future
but rather Millions upon millions of
possible outcomes a web of potential
courses that fate could take and any
decision made could create a new strand
in this already Tangled mess still there
was no outcome where any Scarlet King
existed however it was then that doctor
strange realized what he had been
missing a detail so small that it had
gone unnoticed but so crucial that it
changed his entire approach he had been
thinking of the situation entirely wrong
in an insular fashion that focused
solely on his own reality his universe
but the warning had come from across the
Multiverse from another strange in
another world what's more was the
feeling the sense he'd felt during the
nightmare although he knew nothing of
his enemy strange could tell the
destruction the Scarlet King was capable
of had the reach to threaten all corners
of the Multiverse this wasn't just a
threat to his world but all worlds
strangest search for answers about the
Scarlet King had proved fruitless thus
far yet remembering this was a threat
coming from across the vastness of the
infinite Multiverse oddly seen to
provide some sense of comfort because
there was one entity he did know of who
might be able to help hands a glow with
magic Doctor Strange performed the
correct ritual he knew would allow him
to communicate with the Living Tribunal
Sharon enough the room around him faded
away and he was presented with the
highest Authority in the Multiverse The
Towering vastly powerful entity was
humanoid in shape save for a head
floating separate from its shoulders
with three faces one fully hooded one
half and the other uncovered the
sorcerer's Supreme had conversed on a
few occasions with the entity enough to
know it was responsible for safeguarding
the Multiverse to prevent universes from
amassing too much power in case they
threatened others maintain balance which
made the fact it had done nothing to
prevent the imminent danger of the
Scarlet King all the more concerning
speak strange Living Tribunal I've come
seeking answers Doctor Strange replied
there is a being an entity that poses a
threat to my world and all others in the
Multiverse I am not aware of such a
threat
the multiversal Arbiter replied please
strange urged it's out there and I need
to be the one to stop it there's no
information on it in my universe so I
ask you please tell me where I can find
someone anyone who knows about the
Scarlet King there was a silence for a
moment as the different faces of the
Living Tribunal conferred all three had
to agree on whether or not it could
interfere the answers you seek lie
beyond your universe
the tribunal finally answered we are in
agreement
I will send you there but exercise
caution Stephen strain
in a Flash Doctor Strange had appeared
somewhere new the room was dark filthy
nothing short of Bleak but still was a
far cry from the destruction he had seen
in this Vision the walls were covered in
scribbled writing that had seemingly
been scrawled over every Surface by
someone in a state of Madness there was
one that caught Dr Strange attention a
figure adorned in red armor large
antler-like horns protruding from his
head it didn't take someone with as much
knowledge of sorcerer's Supreme to know
this was a drawing of The elusive
Scarlet King himself who's there a voice
rasped Stephen turned to see an old man
withered and alone laying on a grimy
hospital bed in the corner of the room
sorry I I didn't see you he said calmly
cautiously approaching only lowering his
guard when he heard the elderly man give
a horse cough you're very sick strange
remarked dying I think the man replied
are you Foundation Foundation the
sorcerer echoed in confusion yes yes
don't be surprised I know all about them
the anonymous man said weekly I haven't
forgotten when I used to work there or
how they felt about what I know though
they'd stop at nothing to silence me God
knows they've tried over the years
listen I was sent here because I need
answers Doctor Strange interrupted aware
of the impending threat he felt he
needed to avert so uh Mr doctor
the old man corrected Dr Robert Montauk
Dr Montauk Steven echoed what can you
tell me about this Scarlet King Montauk
started chuckling a dry wheezing sound
almost like he was taunting the sorcerer
his laughter lasted far longer than that
of a sane man paired with the drawings
and markings on the walls Stephen was
certain something inside Robert Montauk
was broken oh I could tell you so much
about the Scarlet gang I was one of his
children once so long ago now he said a
loud hacking cough brought on by his
laughter forced its way out of montauk's
throat
but that's his strength you see being
known being understood look this being
is threatening my world I need to know
how I'm supposed to stop him strange ass
stop him
Dr Montauk chuckled at him what makes
you think you can I was told I have to
the sorcerer's Supreme admitted it has
to be me and if you won't tell me what I
need to know that I'm very sorry
normally I'd never do this but in the
grand calculus of the Multiverse there's
nothing I won't sacrifice to protect it
with the wave of his hands Dr Strange
conjured his third eye which snapped
open in the center of his forehead it
functioned as an organic manifestation
of his Amulet the powerful mystical
artifact known as the eye of agamoto and
through it Stephen peered into Dr
montauk's fractured mind seeking out the
information he was withholding about the
Scarlet King no no no you can't Montauk
shouted his frail withered hands
gripping his temples as he felt the
sorcerer invading his memories I'm sorry
strange repeated but knowledge is power
and I need to know how to stop the
Scarlet King you think knowledge is
power the old man rasped it's more than
that to him it's a weapon his weapon the
more we know about him it was too late
Doctor Strange had found what he was
looking for years earlier Dr Robert
Montauk had been working at the SCP
Foundation and had uncovered the true
nature of scp-001 tough toe's proposal
otherwise known as The Scarlet King The
King was an elder god a force of pure
chaos and the manifestation of a hatred
for modernity but it was far worse than
that a huge Crimson crack split through
the concrete wall a doorway to the
Scarlet King's domain pulling himself
out of Robert montauk's mind the second
he realized his mistake Doctor Strange
was still reeling as the portal opened
how could he have been so stupid his
nightmare hadn't been a warning to
prevent what was coming it was either a
warning to stay away or a trap snapping
back to awareness Steven found he was no
longer in the filthy room where the
dying Dr Robert Montauk lay instead he
was in a vast multiversal void a space
between universes and there among the
huge expanse of nothingness stood the
Scarlet King he towered over Dr Strange
his physical form adorned in armored the
shade of blood atop his head was a
crown-like ornament the large antlers
jutting out above his hands were gnarled
claws clenched into massive fists and
his many eyes were looking at Stephen
having seen inside montauk's mind Doctor
Strange had realized all too late that
the Scarlet King was more than just an
ancient evil being and a desire to
return to a more violent age but if
nobody talked about him he would gain no
further power the Scarlet King had only
grown in strength the more the SCP
Foundation had tried to learn about him
and now the sorcerer Supreme himself had
done the same the king had achieved even
greater power thanks to strange falling
into his trap enough to open a Gateway
and bring him here you already know
the Scarlet King snarled his voice
sounding like billions upon billions of
insects chittering
Stephen looked in horror at the
interdimensional Abomination even just
by observing him being able to receive
his physical form he was unintentionally
empowering The Entity but living idea or
not strange had seen the destruction
that the Scarlet King could unfurl on
the Multiverse by the hoary hosts of
hog'oth Doctor Strange declared
summoning up a spell that he hoped would
reverse whatever power the king
possessed you will not harm my world nor
any others unleashing his magic in a
blast of light the beams struck the
Scarlet King the elder god was harmed
but not undone the force of the Mystic
Arts being almost as ancient as the
Scarlet King was and thus he could still
be hurt the Scarlet King raised a mighty
fist bringing it slamming down towards
Stephen he was barely able to cast The
Shield of seraphim creating a protective
circle of mystical energy that formed a
barrier between strange and the oncoming
attack as the descending gigantic Fist
of the Scarlet King was deflected he
instantly brought his other down in a
vicious attack the sheer force of it
broke Steven's concentration causing the
shield to dissipate barely withstanding
enough of the King's Physical strength
to prevent the sorcerer from being
knocked down it was like one magically
powered ant fighting against a being
impossibly bigger that could stomp
strange out of existence in seconds but
even failing to the imperceptible ground
of the Void Doctor Strange didn't let up
refusing to relent and let the Scarlet
King unleash his wrath on the Multiverse
his cloak of levitation lifted him back
to his feet and with a wave of both
hands Stephen burst into multiple astral
projected copies of himself the images
of Icon the multiple doctors strangers
floated independently through the air
surrounding the Scarlet King then as
every Stephen gave an outward flick of
his wrist the Crimson bands of xidarock
flew from their hands the bright red
belts of energy virtually indestructible
bound the powerful chaotic King lashing
around his physical form Doctor Strange
being able to see and perceive the
Scarlet King was granting his adversary
power he pulled with all his physical
strength the Crimson bands starting to
wane slackening despite Strange's
efforts to keep all his duplicates
holding on ripping the bands in his huge
gnarled hands the Scarlet King swung the
multiple strangers around forcing them
all back into the same singular body as
they collided still holding the one
remaining Crimson band of sirak the
Scarlet King started to drag Stephen
towards him the king didn't want him
dead strange knew it he'd be tortured
made and unmade even until the entity
forced him to use his third eye again
like he had done to Dr Montauk if Doctor
Strange could fully comprehend the
Scarlet King's nature origin and
ideology then the king would be able to
achieve his full strength that was the
Trap the sorcerer Supreme had been lured
into his own arrogance his need to be
the one who saved the Multiverse the man
holding the scalpel was a weakness the
Scarlet King was prepared to exploit in
order to achieve the power he needed to
overthrow the Multiverse there was only
one thing left that doctor strange could
do one last Stitch effort it was a long
shot but he hoped it would be enough
releasing his remaining band Steven
began casting a spell to send a message
to another of his selves somewhere else
in the Multiverse he could hear the
Scarlet King blooming behind him ready
to strike maybe the king would kill him
but strange wouldn't let that stopping
him cast his spell his warning would
reach the other self even after death in
the form of a dream a warning not to
make the same mistake as this strange
had to not go searching for the Scarlet
King ever since she was in high school
Faith had dreamed of moving out and
finally getting a place of her own it
wasn't that she didn't love her parents
she did but they were always around
always coming into her room without
knocking telling her when to go to bed
when to wake up not to eat dinner in
front of the TV in college she had some
welcome Independence but she had to live
with roommates again they were perfectly
nice people some of them she even
considered good friends but she hated
having to share her space having to come
home from a long day of classes and see
someone else's dishes piled up in the
sink to have someone else's music
keeping her awake at night to delay her
morning shower because someone else had
gotten there first so she was thrilled
when a few years after graduating she
got a new job at a marketing company
that would finally let her afford a
place by herself at last she could have
some peace some quiet and most
importantly some privacy Faith spent all
day moving furniture and unpacking boxes
turning the little apartment into a real
home it wasn't much just a main room she
used as a bedroom and living room a
bathroom and a basic little kitchen but
it was all hers and all of the little
personal touches she'd put together
really made it feel like the place was
meant for her there was the orange couch
she picked up at a vintage store
downtown the coffee table she'd gotten
for free from her last roommate bring
pictures of her family and friends a bed
with Linens in her favorite color light
blue and lots and lots of potted plants
over time she would find even more
things more little personal touches to
liven up the space now how to celebrate
her new home her gas wasn't on yet so
she couldn't cook anything but that was
the perfect excuse to order in 30
minutes or less later she was kicking
back on her couch with a large cheese
pizza watching a scary movie on her TV
no one would ask to switch it over to
the bachelor no one would take the last
slice while she was in the bathroom it
was perfect finally A Little Piece of
Heaven an introvert's Paradise as she
finished her first meal in the new place
she felt her eyes beginning to grow
heavy the day of strenuous unpacking
catching up with her body just as she
was thinking about calling it a night a
pale face monster appeared out of
nowhere on screen terrifying the movie's
main character and making Faith jump
spilling her soda all over the coffee
table damn it she
already she'd made a mess but hey she
tried to look on the bright side it was
yet another first to break in the
apartment she grabbed a kitchen towel to
mop up the soda and when she returned to
the main room she froze there was
something in the window standing out
against the darkness outside at first
she thought it was a reflection a trick
of the light but as she slowly
approached the window eyes wide and
hands trembling she got a better look
there was a face a little difficult to
make out as if it were peering Out of
the Shadows but unmistakable nonetheless
it was pale humid vaguely resembling a
strained man with dark circles under his
eyes and he was looking right at her she
didn't scream she was too terrified to
make a sound she stared at the face for
a long moment waiting for it to do
something anything after several moments
of the tenses staring contest of her
life she blinked the face didn't
you you need to leave she finally spoke
surprising herself as she did if you
don't get out of here I'm calling the
cops again the face did nothing do you
hear me her voice climbed in Pitch her
heart pounding against the inside of her
chest who was he what did he want she
became vaguely aware of the fact that
she couldn't see the rest of the man's
body just his face looking at her with a
neutral expression a look of vague
curiosity like someone watching a caged
animal at the zoo might have it was then
she remembered something that made her
blood run cold made the towel drop from
her hands as her stomach sank she lived
on the third floor her apartment had no
balcony no fire escape he could have
climbed up whatever was looking at her
through her window it was no ordinary
peeping Tom she couldn't say how long
she stared at the face its unblinking
eyes it's inscrucible expression she
moved closer to the window step by step
until she was almost nose to nose with
the thing she couldn't think of it as a
person though it looked like one mostly
she should run screaming out the door
looking for some kind of help but what
would she say that there was a floating
face looking at her through the window
what if it was somehow all in her head
some sort of hallucination brought on by
exhaustion and the stress of the move
she raised a fist and following a
passive Instinct wrapped on the glass
she didn't know she expected for it to
Blink to move to knock back to say
something but nothing happened it just
stayed there as if it were part of the
window itself Faith pulled the curtains
closed hiding the strange face from view
with any luck it would be gone in the
morning she had worked hard to get this
apartment and she would be damned if she
let some strange thing whatever it was
drive her out of her new home but as she
climbed into bed and pulled the covers
up to her chin she could still feel its
Gaze on her as if it could see through
the thick fabric of the curtains she
rolled over onto her side her back to
the window and tried her best to forget
about it to shake that horrible feeling
of being observed she lay there for
hours eyes open heart racing but finally
the exhaustion one and she Slipped Away
into sleep she didn't dream at all that
night it was as if she closed her eyes
and seconds later it was morning she
woke to the beep of her alarm feeling as
if she hadn't rested at all the first
thing she did was climb out of the bed
and go to the window carefully
tentatively she opened the curtains she
let out a sigh of deep belief the face
was gone she must have imagined it after
all a bit concerning but as long as it
didn't happen again she wouldn't have
anything to worry about lack of sleep
does strange things to the mind after
all no longer plagues by the fear of
that strange face faith hopped into the
shower and let the worries of the
previous night wash away disappearing
down the drain she brushed her teeth
dried her hair did her makeup and
dressed for work after a banana and a
quick cup of coffee she was out the door
work was exceptionally busy that day and
it pushed any memory of the Oddity in
the window out of her mind entirely she
was even feeling good enough to accept
her friend's offer to grab a drink after
work they met up at a bar down the
street from her new place sharing
cocktails memories and a plate of onion
rings it was a perfect lovely evening by
the time she got home savoring the click
of the key in the lock as she let
herself into her quiet little Sanctuary
she had completely forgotten about the
unusual Apparition she swung the door
open and rushed to dump herself onto the
couch for a bit of TV before bed then
out of the corner of her eye she saw it
the face back in its previous Place
staring at her from the darkness outside
she gaffed at the sight her screamed
catching in her throat it was just as
she remembered it right no something was
different what was it she clapped her
mouth in horror as she identified the
change its expression was different gong
was the vaguely interested neutral
expression now it was smiling at her not
a pleasant smile not a warm friendly
smile a wicked smile twisted and cruel
it knew she was afraid but she'd been
hoping it was gone forever and it was
enjoying itself her hands were shaking
nervous sweat beating on her brow what
do you want from me she whispered
staring into its eyes they didn't move
but they glittered with malicious Glee
just the same what do you want from me
she repeated her voice rising to a shout
shut up her next door neighbor yelled
banging on the wall it's after midnight
she couldn't bring herself to respond
she had more important things to attend
to her stomach turned bile rising in her
throat with the face begun again in the
morning would he come back again at
night was the apartment haunted
possessed by a specter doomed to reside
in her window forever was that why the
rent had been so affordable or maybe it
was her maybe this thing had been drawn
to her or maybe she was losing her mind
unaccustomed to living alone and her
sanity was slipping away she shivered at
the thought what was worse if the face
was on her head or if it wasn't rather
than attempt to answer the question
gnawing at her she closed the curtains
out of sight out of mind she thought she
would have to keep the curtain closed
possibly forever it was better than
seeing that damned face grinning that
horrible grin but as she tried to settle
in for another restless night she could
feel its eyes boring into her burning
into her skull she had never felt so
uneasy before she prepared for
cockroaches for black mold and for
burglars but not for this this was
something outside of her understanding
outside of reality itself just don't
look she whispered to herself just don't
look at it it became part of her daily
routine wake up ignore the window go to
work try to forget about the window get
home try desperately not to think about
the window she could always feel it
though as soon as the sun went down
though she kept the curtains closed she
knew there she thought about checking to
see what face it was making this time
but she couldn't bring herself to look
gradually her condition worsened she
woke up to a tightness in her chest
panic attacks that wrecked her body and
felt like her heart might stop beating
her stomach would ache she struggled to
keep food down one morning she rushed to
the bathroom and spat up blood the
effect began to follow her out of the
apartment too far away from the faces
dwelling she would sit at her desk
struggling to focus on marketing
campaigns and pitches and she would feel
a sudden pain in her stomach forcing her
to double over and groan with Agony she
would see flickers of the pale face in
her peripheral vision turning to look
only to find there was nothing there
when she walked down the hall to the
elevator or down the street outside her
building she would feel as if someone
was following her she never saw anyone
never heard any footsteps coming up
behind her but she could never shake off
the sensation soon even her formerly
dreamless nights of sleep fitful as they
had been became unsafe she would toss
and turn sweating through her sheets as
her subconscious was tormented by
chilling visions and terrible nightmares
she would dream of walking down a long
dark hallway that seemed to go on
forever and something coming up behind
her trying to grab her and drag her away
it would chase her wide dark eyes and
long long limbs grasping at her as she
ran and ran but never escaped other
times she would dream of being locked in
a damp basement chained to a wall as the
pale creature sat in a chair across from
her just watching waiting for something
though she didn't know what every night
another nightmare that made her wake up
screaming fighting off invisible
attackers after two weeks of living in
hell she decided to look out the window
again she had to see had to know that
night when she opened the curtains it
was there mouth wide open eyes glinting
it was laughing at her screw the deposit
enough was an
she wanted her home back she picked up
the heavy lamp on her bedside table
wounded up and threw it out the window
with all her might the glass shattered
little crystalline Shard sprang in every
direction as the lamp flew through the
air out the window and down to the
street below and just like that the face
was gone she checked every other window
in place the little one in the bathroom
the people on her door but it was
nowhere to be found she was free her
knees gave out and she collapsed to the
floor her face in her hands and wept
from sheer relief tomorrow she would
clean up the broken glass and spin her
landlord a story about a freak accident
someone would come to fix the window and
it would be the best money she had ever
spent eventually the whole ordeal would
fade away from memory like a bad dream
but somewhere out there someone else was
living the nightmare all over again
looking out to darkened window to see an
unwelcome Guest The Entity known as
scp-965
scp-965 is a phenomenon affecting framed
windows when it appears it manifests in
the shape of a shadowy face belonging to
a pale man staring in through the window
the details of the man's face vary from
person to person as well as his apparent
age and the direction he is facing
however all reports point to the same
figure at various ages ranging from 10
to 55. the foundation has attempted to
use facial recognition software to
identify a citizen matching the
description of this figure but so far no
one has been found
scp-965 will not appear in just any
window it will only manifest when the
lighting on the outside of the window
drops below illumination of five
candalas the lighting on the inside of
the window does not have any measurable
effect the face will only appear in the
confines of a completely assembled
window frame though the window does not
necessarily need to be installed
anywhere it will only move from one
glass pane to another if its original
point of manifestation is destroyed the
face can be seen from an outside vantage
point though it has been described by
observers as looking away into the room
when scp-965 first appears to someone it
produces feelings of unease anxiety and
low-grade paranoia anyone within the
visual range of the affected window will
experience these feelings even if the
window is covered by curtains or any
other means any individual that sleeps
in an area visible to
scp-965's manifestation point will begin
to experience difficulty sleeping
suffering from upsetting and disturbing
dreams however this is not the end point
of the entity's impact on those it
appears to at a point between 3 and 10
nights of sleep after its initial
appearance the entities facial
expression will begin to shift into a
noticeable smile after the shift the
victim's symptoms will become physical
as well as mental including ulcers and
intestinal bleeding heartburn abdominal
pain and even vomiting blood this has
been attributed to the entity's
influence on the human body's reaction
to heightened levels of stress fear the
subjects that reach this stage of
exposure to scp-965 begin to see its
face in Windows in their dreams as well
as spotting it in their peripheral
vision while going about their Waking
Life they begin to see the face out of
the corner of their eye even when the
affected window is nowhere in sight
these additional sightings are
accompanied by lingering feelings of
paranoia and The Sensation that
something is following or watching them
though the entity has never made a sound
and does not move while it is visible it
can disappear and reappear in different
poses it has also displayed notable
signs of sentience appearing
disappointed when it manifests in an
empty room and angry if it sees someone
who broke its previous window when
presented with one of the agents who
first brought it into custody The Entity
appeared frightened for the first time
testing involving scp-965 involving the
destruction of its host window confirmed
that a multi-paned window might act as
multiple holding zones but significant
damage to its overall structure keeps it
from being a viable replacement in this
particular case the entity manifested in
a nearby experimentation Chambers
observation window which was promptly
destroyed in order to prevent any
potential breaches for a month following
this incident The Entity manifested with
noticeably hostile facial expressions
clearly resentful of its treatment only
one other notable incident has occurred
so far during the course of
scp-965's containment by the SCP
Foundation Dr Al the rest of her name
has been redacted from the official file
was the head researcher assigned to
scp-965 for several months before she
filed an official request for transfer
to a different test subject she was
beginning to experience intrusive
visions of scp-965 and lingering
feelings of paranoia lasting long after
she left the foundation signed her
symptoms were consistent with those of
someone who had slept in the presence of
the entity though she swore up and down
she had never napped or slept at all in
the vicinity of the affected window she
was temporarily relieved of her duties
and provided with psychological care so
far no other instances of scp-965
impacting staff who have not slept in
its presence have been reported but this
case set an unsettling precedent the
mental health of anyone assigned to
scp-965 is to be strictly monitored in
case it expands its influence again
scp-965 is contained within a framed
ready to install window made up of six
panes of clear glass or other comparable
material at a size of at least 15
centimeters by 30 centimeters the window
must be kept in an environmentally
controlled storage facility capable of
withstanding earthquakes and other
seismic activity the window must be
inspected at least once a week in order
to check the Integrity of the material
additionally at least two identical
framed windows must be stored in the
same facility in separate Chambers with
additional insulation any Lighting in
the containment chamber should be kept
at minimum of 130 Candelas at any time
Personnel are inside with the exception
of research and experimentation though
scp-965 is currently contained the
foundation is unable to control its
movement should its current window be
destroyed therefore scp-965 is
classified as Euclid scopeup phobia is
the fear of being watched or looked at
by others those suffering from this fear
will often avoid Windows terrified of
who might be standing on the other side
staring in and keeping track of
everything they do even those of us
without scopophobia might find ourselves
feeling a prickle of dread while looking
out the window at night watching for a
shadowy figure or a ghastly face pressed
to the glass most of the time of course
there is no one there it's just an
overactive imagination the lingering
effect of watching one too many scary
movies but eventually your luck might
just run out one night when the world
Falls quiet and you go to close the
curtains before you go to sleep just in
case you might just feel that someone is
right there on the other side of that
thin pane of glass staring at you with
wide unblinking eyes it won't ever come
inside but it isn't going anywhere and
as long as you are where it can see you
you will never know peace again when it
comes to beings with fearsome
reputations there are few scps that are
as widely dreaded as the hard to destroy
reptile
scp-682 no sane mortal would ever choose
to face such a creature and its
overwhelming ferocity and strength have
even given the reincarnating warrior
scp-076-2 able pause on more than one
occasion but then again this saying
aren't exactly in high demand at the SCP
Foundation or at equivalent
organizations formed for the purpose of
battling anomalous and Supernatural
entities organizations such as the
public safety devil hunters from the
popular Manga and Anime chainsaw man
count numerous peculiar individuals
among their ranks and sometimes the best
of the best are marked by a distinctive
tendency for out of the box thinking
that's putting it politely at least but
this isn't the story of some aberrant
loser Freakazoid no definitely not the
hair island of this tale is none other
than the mightiest and most charismatic
future Nobel Prize winner ever to Grace
the rest of us shameful worms with her
presence the Invincible and dearly
beloved blood fiend power who just so
happens to be the Undisputed best
character in chainsaw man and of all
fiction as well it appeared to be an
unusually Boring Day At Public Safety
and for this kobeni was grateful the
young woman had come to expect the
absolute worst from her job as a devil
Hunter as her assignments usually
entailed facing down hellish entities
born from the very fears of the human
race while one would think that someone
who worked so diligently in the field
would have grown numb to it all kobeni
still very much retained her anxieties
both on and off the job at least all she
had to do today was file paperwork from
one of the public safety's like-minded
Partners in Supernatural management the
SCP Foundation it was a safe and
harmless task aside from the risk of
paper cuts and the associated potential
for the paper cut devil to show up even
so kobeni would do her best to make this
rare moment of Peace last as long as
possible a voice cried from down the
hallway oh no not her cobeni thought why
is she even at work today she's a
fighter for division four and she's not
good at anything else loud exaggerated
footsteps rang out through the hallway
as the blood fiends stomped through the
offices of Public Safety cabani wanted
to shrink until she vanished from sight
or let herself sink into the floor her
desire to not have to see Power today
was so great that she contemplated
opening a window and climbing down this
side of the building to the ground floor
please don't come this way gobeni was
still carrying a heavy stack of freshly
filed paperwork and she didn't want her
tireless efforts at organization to go
to waste she looked frantically at the
cabinets in the storage room she was in
hoping to find enough space for her to
crawl into and make herself scarce but
it was to too late power slammed open
the door of the storage room and
announced her presence the shock was so
great that kobeni screamed and flung the
stack of SCP Foundation papers all over
the ground she clutched her fast Beating
Heart unable to attend to the mess
immediately kobene hadn't had to
experience a fright that sudden since
the time that she was sent to hunt the
jump scare devil the poor girl could
never have a surprise party thrown in
her honor again Drew to her name power
immediately reprimanded cobeni for
dropping the papers stating that her
workmanship was sloppy and that power
herself could easily carry 10 times the
amount of paper kobeni tried to not let
the chatting of her co-worker affect her
mood she bent down and scooped up the
papers but much to her Chagrin power
decided to help with this task as well
the bloodstream began grabbing the
papers and stacking them as assertively
as possible on the nearest surfaces
resulting in many crumpled edges and
uneven piles kobeni attempted albeit
hesitantly to correct Powers paper
collect method only to be met with more
scorn gobending nearly cried this was
just too much for her to handle
especially on what was supposed to be a
calm day that was when power picked up
one of the files and began to read it
was a record of the infamous cross-test
between
scp-682 and
scp-076-2 since Public Safety had
previously assisted the foundation in
re-containing
scp-076-2 there had been an agreement to
send copies of all relevant documents
involving Abel over to Japan in case of
another incident as power struggled
through the scientific language and
specifics she began to Envision her own
version of the events that played out on
the page she imagined herself as able
facing off in pitched combat against
scp-682 and giving the terrible lizard a
run for its money in the process in the
mere seconds it took for power to finish
reading the document she had not only
concocted an entire epic battle in mind
but was not fully events that her
fantasy was indistinguishable from one
of her own lived experiences in her head
power had definitely fought against
scp-682 and she do it again in a
heartbeat just to teach that overgrown
reptile another lesson power asks kobeni
if she had ever told her about the time
that the blood fiend had totally
defeated
scp-682 kobene is still clutching to her
increasingly frail understanding of
reality responded with confusion what
was she talking about nobody in public
safety had fought against an SCP other
than
076-2 there was no possible way that
power was telling the truth but the
scariest part was power herself didn't
even know that she was lying the blood
fiend began to relate the Sora details
of her pulse-pounding fight with scp-682
tukubeni in great detail cabani for her
part was too emotionally drained at this
point to try and stop her it all started
at the bowling alley Where power was
hanging out with her much less
intelligent friends Aki and denji the
bloodfiend had just finished winning her
fifth perfectly scored game in a row
when some shady characters a few lanes
over decided to cause some trouble the
leader of this little gang was none
other than
scp-682 the way you ball is disgusting
the troublemaking lizard said this
wicked remark would not be stood for not
in the proud bowling establishment that
power had founded with her own money and
achieved several years of successful
business running herself the bowling
alley was a pillar of the community and
she was the owner there would be no
further disrespect on her watch power
put up her dukes and got ready to bring
the pain down on scp-682 Aki and denji
were too terrified to help her out as
usual but did their best to cheer their
leader on from the sidelines
scp-682 also dismissed its minions and
called forward like the big ugly lizard
that it was it obviously didn't know
better which is is why it wasn't backing
down in the face of the greatest devil
hunter that the world had ever known
either way this would be a Brawl for the
ages rather than cause damage to her
beloved place of business power
suggested that she and her opponent took
this fight outside despite its uncouth
demeanor the reptile had a healthy
appreciation for the fine sport of
bowling and most especially this
particularly excellent run five-star
bowling alley it agreed to step outside
in the interest of not bringing bowling
into this intensely personal Grudge
Match but then again wasn't the fight
about bowling no matter power and
scp-682 walked outside the bowling alley
into a vast trackless Wasteland the
perfect place for both of them to go all
out without hurting any civilians using
her ability to control and reshape her
own blood power constructed an enormous
Crimson Mallet that she was able to
wield gracefully in both her hands
despite its incredible size scpc 682
readied itself it had faced many
different kinds of humanoid weapon
wielders before including Abel but it
was too clever of an adversary to let
its guard down especially because in
this case the blood fiend it was
fighting was a remarkable businesswoman
and an Olympic gold medalist in
everything the reptile certainly let its
card down power held the hammer above
her head and jumped High into the air if
she wanted to she could have circled the
globe in a single leap but out of
respect for the fact that scp-682 was a
paying customer at her establishment she
decided to hold back for the first
attack at least nonetheless she brought
the hammer down on the hard to destroy
reptile with Supreme Force
scp-682 smashed into the ground with
such a force that a crater opened up
beneath its body the reptile itself
didn't seem especially damaged but the
effects on the surrounding environment
were certainly dramatic and fitting for
an Ultimate Showdown
scp-682 shook off the blow and pounced
on power such ferocity that even she
couldn't remain on her feet she tumbled
back into the dust and debris of the
Wasteland for several miles before
catching herself and standing back up
remarkably there wasn't even a scratch
on her she pointed and laughed at
scp-682 mocking it for its weakness and
stupidity the reptile grinned wickedly
and responded with a mocking laugh of
its own the creature had intentionally
taken a hit from power in order to
better understand her fighting moves who
wouldn't want to steal those masterful
techniques after all they're just too
good to resist making a cheap copy of
and from what power could remember from
her speed read of the file that appeared
to be
scp-682's whole thing soon a barting of
blood red armor appeared around
scp-682's body in the short time that it
had been fighting Power it had clearly
learned how to manipulate its own blood
and was now even stronger for it ha ha
ha
now I'm as strong as you I can't lose
scp-682 barked at Power she swung her
Mallet in a show of force the two
combatants now both wielding the near
Limitless powers of the blood fiend
charged at each other across the
battlefield this was not just a mere
sparring match anymore it was a fight
for the fate of the entire world
snapping back to reality Powers
retelling of the story had devolved into
a series of random exclamations and
sound effects cabani was now finding the
events incredibly hard to follow but
thankfully she had been able to use
powers highly distractible mannerisms to
finish restacking the files from the
foundation not a minute too soon either
as both she and Powers boss makima
stepped into the storage room apparently
makima was in the process of doing a
headcount of all employees who had come
into work today as any normal and
benevolent Superior would she had been
looking for cobenian power for some time
now and was surprised to find them here
of all places cabani explained that she
had been putting away the last of the
SCP Foundation files and would badly
accept whatever new post she was given
but Power wasn't done with her current
scp-682 Fascination and turned to makama
hoping to be encouraged to continue the
story makama simply smiled and implied
that if power was so inclined to settle
her score with a hard to destroy reptile
Public Safety could get in contact with
the foundation and have her on a flight
to psych 19 by that evening power
suddenly realized that she had come down
with a terrible case of whatever
crippling disease that would be a
sufficient excuse for her to not do that
makima nodded and encouraged her
subordinates to return to work that's
right it's that time again we're
recalibrating rebooting and hitting
restart on our Infamous onomatron 6000
the specialized supercomputer we've
developed to simulate improbable
scenarios between the SCP foundation's
various anomalies and any other
characters from any other Universe you
could possibly imagine on today's agenda
what do you think would happen if John
Wick the notorious Hitman highly trained
in all forms of combat was up against an
enemy that won't go down in a single
shot an undead Menace known as
scp-008 well we're about to hit the
button and find out either by a pure
unpredictable instance of human error or
through the act of some Twisted karmic
fate the SCP Foundation had an outbreak
on their hands a sample of the complex
prion a virus known as scp-008 had
leaked the foundation had hoped to keep
the existence of the disease highly
classified even among its own Personnel
Their Fear had been that some hostile
force would attempt to synthesize or
even weaponize as cp008 after all the
disease had a 100 rate of both infection
and lethality it killed anything it came
into contact with or at least it killed
them to begin with before long everyone
in the foundation facility that had been
exposed to the leaking sample of
scp-008's already infected victims was
flu-like symptoms were followed swiftly
by a coma however the disease hijacked
the bodies of all those it had passed to
reactivating the motor functions of
their corpses and turning them into well
you can already guess no one was safe
even the mobile task force on the scene
were soon infected with scp-008 they had
been a squad of rookies and fresh-faced
new recruits sent in by the foundation
under the assumption that an outbreak of
this sort should have been easy to
contain it wasn't the entire facility
was soon overrun the bodies of
foundation researchers security officers
and MTF troops reanimated after their
deaths now jostling around in search of
survivors to pass scp-008 onto that
should hold them Dr Alto cleff yelled
locking the entrance to the Watchtower
tight this really is another fine mess
clef his colleague Dr gears replied in
frustration our MTF backup are all down
we could be the last two people on site
were locked in a Tower with only one
entry tell me what the hell are we
supposed to do now I will relax clef
insisted don't worry there's someone we
can call to get us out of this jam oh
don't say I know a guy your side as his
fellow researcher gave a wide grin and
reach for his cell phone a few moments
later and only a matter of miles away
another phone started ringing its owner
a man in a dark all-black tailored suit
with a shadowy shirt and tied a match
reached into his pocket and lifted his
cell phone to his ear good evening I
apologize for calling you at this hour
came the unmistakable voice of Sharon a
concierge of the New York Continental
Hotel that's quite all right replied the
suited man we received the call asking
for your whereabouts sir a job the man
asked in a monotone voice indeed Sharon
replied up front I'm afraid not the
hotel's receptionist answered
sympathetically the contract is only in
exchange for payment upon completion the
man who made car was very insistent he
said he would be in no position to pay
until the job is done but he asked for
you specifically and told us he'd be
grateful for your assistance the man on
the end of the line side where oh don't
worry sir the friendly concierge replied
we were sending a car for you at that
precise moment a yellow New York Cab
pulled up to the sidewalk best of luck
Mr Quick Sharon said before hanging up
the call straightening his suit the
infamous Hitman John Wick climbed into
the back of the taxi As It sped off
towards its destination arriving at a
complex Upstate far off the Beaten Track
John examined his surroundings while the
car inched closer to the nearest part of
the facility his ears of training as an
assassin under the tutelage of ruskroma
had given him an instinctive spatial
awareness one that came in handy in his
line of work but even then Jon couldn't
have predicted that something would come
leaping down from above crashing through
the cat's windshield the car's Hood
buckled under the impact fragments of
glass sprang everywhere as an arm
cracked the front window the thing
snarled and gurgled like a wild animal
as it reached for the taxi driver
gripping his arm it pulled him by the
wrist Biting Down causing him to scream
in intense pain meanwhile Jon had
already moved with lightning fast
reflexes and sprung out of the back seat
he hadn't had a chance to assess the
threat his instincts told him his best
option was put some distance between
himself and whatever had just attacked
the car then he'd be able to get a
better idea what he was dealing with the
job description he'd been hired for had
been light on details John's mystery
employer only referred to it as a quote
cleanup operation sprinting towards the
facility John slammed the door behind
him he pulled off his belt from around
his waist and wrapped it tightly around
the door handles it would hold for now
it was only when he turned around that
he saw a few clustered groups of figures
shuffling around inside the building's
atrium the nearest Gaggle were close
enough that it was easy for John to make
out their pale skin sunken eyes and
cheeks the unnatural twitches and
erratic movements they were making as
the creatures turned to look back at him
zombies John Wick muttered under his
breath that's unexpected the nearby Trio
of scp-008 infecties looked like they
were about to make a dash towards him so
Jon moved fast he raced towards a nearby
Corridor hearing that the three zombies
were already chasing after him their
shambling footsteps had quickly become
an animalistic charge their limbs only
able to move after death thanks to the
virus that they were infected with
turning a corner John Wick took cover
his shoulder pressed to the wall he drew
his pistol from its holster underneath
his suit jacket and stood in a
battle-ready stance the second he saw
one of the zombies faces appear around
the corner he raised his weapon and
fired swooping around one of his hiding
places to fire another two shots all
three hit Center Mass right through
their chests the noise would no doubt
have drawn the attention of the other
scp-008s in the building but for now the
three that had been on his tail dropped
to the floor only to start getting back
up again Jon wasn't used to his Target
standing to their feet after he'd
already fired at them and the nearest of
the zombies staggered back to his level
he lifted his firearm again before his
finger could compress enough force on
the trigger though the undead
Abomination took a wild flailing swipe
at him the scp-008 instance knocked the
weapon out of Jon's hand causing it to
clander to the ground while it reared
back its other arm for a second strike
catching the blow John Wick displayed
his incredible reflexes and Mastery of
martial arts he delivered a series of
precise punches and chops deploying a
combination of Brazilian Jiu Jitsu Akito
and Krav Maga to try and knock the
snarling monster down with each hit he
was careful to avoid the zombie's mouth
having seen one bite to the cab driver
earlier Jon had assessed that scp-008
could be transmitted through body and he
was correct exposure to mucous membranes
or bodily fluids of an infected
individual was what allowed the virus to
spread one of the other scp-008 zombies
that were still in the process of
climbing back up swipe John's legs out
from underneath him the master assassin
toppled over landing on his back with
the weight of the first Monster still on
top of him while the second clawed of
this tapered suit pants seconds before
it could snap its teeth down on his
ankle Jon pulled back his leg and shot
it back out in a devastating bicycle
kick that sent the second zombie reeling
into the third which was still trying to
get back up after its earlier gunshot
but the first of the creatures were
still bearing down on him mustering as
much of his Peak Physical strength as he
needed John Wick held the zombie at Bay
blocking it with one arm stopping it
from getting close enough to bite him
his eyes started around looking for
something anything he could use that was
one of Jon's most enviable and
impressive skills one that made him so
renowned as a legend of the Assassin
world in the hands of John Wick any
ordinary everyday object could be a
Lethal Weapon reaching out with this
other hand Jon felt his fingertips brush
against something metal who was so close
just Out Of Reach on top of him the
zombie flown its arms trying to clod him
lifting both legs in a fluid balletic
motion John Wick kicked the creature off
of him crawling towards the nearby
object and grabbing it just as the
zombie started to approach again with
the swing and a loud metallic clang the
heavy fire extinguisher collided with
the scp-008 infecties had the force of
the blow caused it to drop in an instant
Landing in a heap on the floor Jon
waited a second to see if it would get
back up again but it was still the other
two zombies suddenly dashed towards the
infamous Hitman only for their prey to
duck and weave effortlessly between
their aggressive clawing swipes bashing
his makeshift weapon against their heads
like a battering ram against a door all
three were down but the entire facility
was still crawling with a mass of the
reanimated monstrosities calmly John
smoothed his suit and straightened up
his shirt and tie walking with the fire
extinguisher in hand back down the
corridor towards the sound of more
scp-008 zombies snarling they were next
the Baba Yaga would use anything he
found to take down each and every one of
them until not one was left standing it
didn't matter if all he had was a fire
extinguisher or one of the Fallen
security officers batons or even just a
tiny pencil nothing would make it out of
that facility alive
just had to go for the head still
trapped in the Watchtower Dr clef and Dr
gears have long since grown irritated
with each other's company they had no
security feeds no way of knowing what
was going on within the overrun
Foundation facility for a while the pair
of researchers had been toying with the
idea of climbing out of a window and
scaling down the side of the tower but
giving up on that plan when they'd
realized they'd only be dropping back
into a horde of scp-008 zombies a sudden
explosion erupted from one corner of the
complex causing gears and cleft to
direct their attention towards it from
their elevation they could see the
ground below was littered with the
bodies of the scp-008 infecties rendered
lifeless once again by significant
cranial trauma in short something had
been bashing the zombies in the head or
someone the sound of a banging against
the locked Watchtower door startled both
Foundation scientists instantly they
thought that the zombies had made their
way up the steps and found the two
researchers easy prey trapped in a cage
the heavy thought against the metal door
repeated then there was a pause
deafening tense silence filling the room
a polite knock came from the other side
of the Watchtower entrance cautiously
clef approached to a market standing in
the doorway as it opened was a single
figure panting with exhaustion but still
nowhere near Beaton he looked out at
clef and gears from his dark hair a
Stern expression on his face neither one
of the researchers could believe that he
was still alive still uninfected but
then again he was the one and only John
Wick the Baba Yaga in 1914 an Archduke
of Austria-Hungary was shot by a Serbian
nationalist this led after a series of
Nations signing treaties with other
nations to one of the bloodiest
conflicts ever fought a war that was
unlike any that had been fought at the
time trench combat mud and sandbags
newer deadlier advancements in the art
of warfare vile and cure and fatal
diseases and months upon months of
Misery all while trapped in dark dank
dugouts the Great War the first world
war it's gone by many names since its
ceasefire in 1918 and while there aren't
many left of the generation that
remembers it there are still plenty of
scars left on the world that remind us
of the horrors but there's one that
seems to be keeping those wounds fresh
reminding us that war is indeed hell as
that rough Beast slouches towards its
destination this is
scp-2574 what appears from the outset to
be nothing more than a stone sculpture
of a lion comprised of sandstone and
living tissue standing at around 12
meters tall
scp-2574 is much more than a mere statue
in fact it is a living creature after
all this is the SCP Foundation we're
talking about here where inanimate
objects are rarely inanimate at all or
will at least possess some form of
anomalous properties setting apart
anything ordinary and thus drawing the
interest of the foundation
scp-2574 is similar in that regard and
not just for being a living statue
creature for one the anomaly is capable
of movement albeit at a gradual rate
that only progresses between three and
five kilometers per day attempts by the
foundation to slow or halt the movement
of scp-25 74 have been so far
unsuccessful as it seems that any
obstacle placed in its path are unable
to deter it this includes both man-made
and naturally occurring obstructions
meaning there is little that can be
deployed to keep
scp-2574 physically contained even if a
body of water is in its path The Entity
can swim at a rate of between two and
three kilometers per day and will
normally either crush or climb over any
obstacle on land at the previous annual
budgeting meeting the top minds of the
foundation's accounting department
revealed to an infuriated o5 Council
that
scp-2574 had been responsible for an
estimated total of 25.3 million US
dollars in Damages since its Discovery
the second most pressing matter raised
during that presentation was that 112
deaths and a further 625 injuries the
anomaly had also caused despite I please
from the Ethics Committee the foundation
accountants were still adamant that the
cost of Damages was more significant now
a number of prevailing questions might
be plaguing you regarding
scp-2574 for one what does this creature
want if it has freedom of movement and
can't be physically obstructed by the
foundation then is it just aimlessly
wandering free and causing wanton
destruction or does it have a specific
want or goal it seeks to attain and for
another what does an almost 40-foot tall
lion have to do with World War One while
it might surprise you to know that
scp-2574 has everything to do with the
Great War literally everything and as
for a goal it has won or rather it has a
specific destination it seems to be
gradually heading towards and if it
makes it all the way there it could
spell disaster for the entire globe in
fact it could plunge us back into one of
the most devastating conflict the world
has ever seen can you guess which one
scp-2574 possesses a wide array of
latent anomalous effects Beyond its
General functionality and movement above
the Sandstone line creature it is
constantly surrounded by A Flock of
around 6 000 Birds of Prey any that find
themselves flying into the path of
scp-2574 are assimilated into the
growing flock designated as
scp-2574-1 the mass of birds is fixated
on attacking
scp-2574 swooping low to strike at its
smooth muscle tissue with using their
beaks and Talons this however seems to
do little to deter
scp-2574 from making progress as the
anomaly constantly regenerates from
physical damage it incurs from
scp-2574-1 perhaps the most notable and
noticeable of
scp-2574's anomalous properties is the
effect it has on its surroundings as it
progresses towards its destination the
area around
scp-2574 will undergo a physical
transformation in response to the
presence of the lion this transformation
results in the nearby region temporarily
becoming a World War One era combat zone
the ground below becomes riddled with
trenches carved through the Earth thick
muddy bogs and coiled razor-sharp Nets
of barbed wire litter the area the
change triggered by
scp-2574 is hardly just a cosmetic one
either the foundation have observed a
number of First World War related
manifestations that occur in the wake of
scp-2574 man-made land masses like
trenches and dugouts will appear nearby
the front lines reappearing after more
than a century Weaponry from the area is
also present following the arrival of
scp-2574 and this isn't just limited to
Firearms World War one was one of the
earliest large-scale con conflicts in
history where in both sides deployed
aerial attacks through the use of
biplanes as well as chemical warfare as
a result signs of these can also be
found whenever
scp-2574 is nearby but again the
transformation
scp-2574 brings about is not just
limited to recreating battlefields what
some of you may not know is the Great
War did not so much revolve around a
core idealistic difference between both
sides as its successor did instead the
first world war was a geopolitical
grudge match between large Global
superpowers attempting to make grandiose
displays of their amassed military
strength the assassination of Archduke
Franz Ferdinand of Austria at the hands
of a Serbian extremist group was the
Catalyst that set off a chain reaction
of events that ultimately led to War as
a result of this
scp-2574's anomalous influence also
extends to the social and political
state of the areas it enters a country
that the Sandstone leonine entity enters
will suffer a rapid change in its local
population's mentality the ordinary
people living there will start to
experience a great degree of discontent
towards their government while the
ruling powers of said country will
increase its use of force against its
own civilians this effect is more
noticeably potent when scp-2574
interacts with countries that were
directly involved in the first world war
increasing levels of civil unrest and
discontentment among the population
these are often countered with
worryingly increased levels of police
brutality along with governments
enacting aggressive foreign policies and
sometimes antagonizing other countries
as if they are eager to fight these
effects don't necessarily worsen the
closer
scp-2574 gets to a particular country
but do seem to increase the more it
approaches its predicted destination and
where is that you may ask the foundation
have calculated that based on
scp-2574's trajectory since its
emergence back in 2012. the entity is
headed for the city of Sarajevo the
capital city of Bosnia and Herzegovina
what possible reason could
scp-2574 have for wanting to venture
towards this specific Bosnian City well
one cursory glance at the history of
Sarajevo will give you the answer it's
where the assassination of Archduke
Franz Ferdinand took place the event
commonly attributed with starting the
first world war the transformative
effects
scp-2574 has on its surroundings began
when the leonine Leviathan first
appeared and commenced its Journey
towards Sarajevo on December 24 2012.
since then the SCP Foundation has been
closely monitoring the Sandstone
creatures movements and attempting to
log all of the anomalous effects it has
had over the course of making its way
closer to the site of Franz ferdinand's
assassination over 5000 kilometers away
to the east of kazakhstan's capital
Astana
scp-2574 caused an unusual World War One
anomalous effect any written works
published in either Russian or Kazakh
began to randomly feature passages from
Irish poet w b Yates these extracts from
his body of work range from single
sentences to entire poems being featured
in other writers Publications regardless
of author or genre Yates for anyone
unfamiliar was widely considered one of
the greatest Poets of the 20th century
however unlike the authors of numerous
poems and songs to come out of the first
world war W.B Yates was never directly
involved in the conflict itself and
didn't write much about it barring a few
notable exceptions but more on him in a
moment when
scp-2574 approached Russia things
started to escalate
clouds of deadly chlorine gas an early
World War one chemical weapon began
forming in rural areas throughout Europe
that couldn't be dispersed for days at a
time as soon as the Towering anomaly got
close enough Russian military forces
began launching a series of drone
strikes and aerial bombardments
targeting
scp-2574 when these attacks failed
tensions mounted with bordering
countries the situation only getting
worse when it was discovered through an
intelligence leak that Russia was
planning a nuclear strike against the
creature a move that likely could have
spelled disaster for the neighboring
countries
scp-2574 of course sustained no damage
and continued on its course given that
they couldn't physically contain
scp-2574 the foundation was forced to
think outside of the box when it came to
coming up with some kind of solution
there were already too many eyewitnesses
aware of the leonine leviathan's
existence to consider administering
amnestics even on a large scale the fact
was too many people already knew about
scp-2574 and would make such a move
pointless the best that the foundation
could do to combat if not counteract the
effects of
scp-2574 was to work directly with
governments affected by the creatures
World War One transformative effects to
try and repair the damage left in the
anomalies wake and ease the tension and
violence it caused it became the
foundation's job to deter any country
planning and armed military response to
the presence of
scp-2574 as any such strike would
endanger both their military and
civilian populations while causing no
damage to the anomaly in the interest of
trying to solve the problems posed by
scp-2574 reverting parts of Europe to
hellish First World War era battlefields
the foundation made a rare agreement to
collaborate with another large
organization specializing in in the
anomalous the global occult Coalition
working directly with the GOC their goal
was to create a large-scale memetic
countermeasure that would effectively
reset the toll
scp-2574 had exacted on global
Psychology by altering people's
temperaments and creating mass political
unrest as it progressed towards the
Bosnian Capital however given the tense
history between the SCP Foundation and
the global occult Coalition their
attempts at creating a memetic
countermeasure are still ongoing since
neither group wants the other to engage
them in full-scale mimetic Warfare as
such the proposed countermeasure will
consist of two parts with neither
organization being able to replicate the
other's half meanwhile
scp-2574's progress across Europe was
responsible for a number of other
significant changes physically socially
and politically recreating the
conditions of the first world war
poppies a flower that is since become
synonymous with the remembrance of the
conflict began to grow in regions within
Russia where they wouldn't naturally
occur this included within Urban
locations the red flowers sprouting in
and around buildings as a result of such
a high profile anomaly causing such
widespread unrest to spread a number of
religious cults centered around
scp-2574 began to form while the living
descendants of World War One veterans
began suffering from Vivid
hallucinations that depicted their
ancestors first-hand experience of the
fighting these Cults began to amass more
and more of those affected by
scp-2574 the SCP Foundation was able to
observe some of the sermons delivered by
these religious cults who appeared to
view the public appearances of
scp-2574 as signs of an impending
apocalypse
us and embrace your salvation one cult
leader exclaimed in a sermon discover
the words of the Prophet Yates who spoke
this sacred truth that all of history is
a spiral and that we have spiraled
outwards towards chaos land the true
nature of the second coming it appeared
that some of these Cults viewed the
Poetry of WB Yates as prophetic in
regards to
scp-2574 they would often reference the
second coming which interestingly was
the name of one of his poems written in
the aftermath of World War One Yates is
the second coming refers to a rough
Beast slouching towards Bethlehem the
SCP Foundation has since uncovered some
erratic writings made by the poet before
his death that allude to Bethlehem
despite no record existing of him ever
traveling there it is believed that
Yates somehow figured out what
scp-2574 was and that The Closer it gets
to its destination the more civilization
will spiral further out of control
towards total all-consuming chaos
further research by the foundation also
uncovered a testimony made by gavrilo
princip the Serbian man responsible for
assassinating Archduke Franz Ferdinand
of Austria and thus sparking the first
world war princeip seems to have had
some knowledge about
scp-2574 and apparently killed the
Archduke as a way to begin the
creature's journey in order to make
Society more chaotic with
scp-2574 progressing worryingly closer
to the side of Franz ferdinand's
assassination further chaos rapidly
began to spread anarchic sentiments took
hold of most of Europe leading to an
increased rate of violent encounters
between civilians and police in many
countries including Ireland France Great
Britain and Italy with a number of these
experiencing widespread rioting in their
major population centers any government
or political party come compelled by
scp-2574 to openly espouse the same
Anarchist sentiments we're soon seeing a
rapid increase in their public approval
gaining more popularity in polls than
their opposition as a result of these
heightened tensions between the public
and the government of their countries
assassination attempts of politicians
saw an alarming increase of around 60
percent
scp-2574 caused countries that have
existing hostile relations to engage in
armed skirmishes at their borders with
at least one of these battles occurring
every two weeks and each time
threatening to spark a much larger scale
conflict thanks to the anomalies of
facts the international tensions
dissolving alliances between countries
and Adoption of nationalism which were
all factors leading to the start of the
Great War were beginning to rapidly
spread once again by the time
scp-2574 was around 550 kilometers from
Sarajevo people began experiencing
injuries common among soldiers during
World War One many patients would die
during surgery only for their bodies to
disappear shortly afterwards conflict
erupted between Ireland and England it
has scp-2574 entered Bosnia and
Herzegovina many began to report
suffering intense dreams about the
anomaly a number of these reports seemed
to state that
scp-2574 was attempting to communicate
with them and multiple websites begin
logging the Sandstone Lions appearance
in their dreams and things will only get
worse the closer
scp-2574 gets to Sarajevo
scp-2574 contains the raw energy of
world war one one of the most
catastrophic events in human history a
global conflict with a death toll in the
tens of millions the SCP Foundation
estimates it'll reach the site of Franz
ferdinand's assassination within a month
and from that point given the effect
it's had on the of Europe there's only
one likely outcome when that rough bee
slouches towards its ultimate
destination War
a giant monstrous crab-like claw closes
around the throat of an unimaginably
huge eel-like Beast the beast's terrible
writhing tentacles wrap around and latch
onto the immense crustacean and then the
high intensity beams of gamma radiation
start flying all the while Legions of
skinless Centaur swim in the waters
around them relishing the violence and
in the middle a lone boat the scps
Smither manned by a team of mobile task
force operatives that does all it can
just to survive there are those who
consider outer space to be the ultimate
achievement in Exploration the one place
that explorers have yet to chart and
understand however some of the murkiest
Mysteries in the universe are on our own
Planet deep down at the bottom of the
ocean 95 of the deep ocean remains
completely unexplored and the little
glimpses we have gotten paint a picture
of something truly alien giant squids
organisms that can breathe nitrogen
luminescent predatory fish and sharks as
old as the Earth itself even the SCP
Foundation is still struggling to fully
grasp the depth of the ocean and the
strange beings that dwell there one of
the most unusual aquatic findings in the
history of the foundation is that of
scp-3700
scp-3700 refers to a circular area in
the North Sea with a diameter of 800
kilometers the waters there are
abnormally deep for the region with the
sea floor resting at five kilometers
beneath the ocean's surface there are
two entities present in the waters of
scp-3700 designated
scp-3700-1 and
scp-3700-2 interactions between these
two entities are responsible for the
anomalous changes to the meteorological
and geological conditions in the area
scp-3700-1 and
scp-3700-2 always interact on the spring
and fall equinoxes of any given year but
they will also engage one another
throughout the year seemingly at random
but what exactly are as CP 3700-1 and
scp-3700-2 aside from terrifying
creatures of the deep
scp-3700-1 is an arthropod bearing an
aesthetic resemblance to the European
Lobster only much much bigger measuring
six kilometers in length the creature is
green with a mix of blue yellow pink and
red markings across the top of its
exoskeleton that bear the appearance of
a woman's face it has six prehensile
limbs four of which terminate in Claws
and eight legs the entity's four eyes
are compound and orange attached to
stalks anyone who gets close enough to
observe the creature's carapace in
detail will notice scars cracks and
small holes indicating years and years
of damage scp-3700
1 has several anomalous qualities in
addition to its size in a fight it is
able to strike with its appendages and
produce cavitation bubbles with a force
greater than several tons of Dynamite
two of the entity's eyes are capable of
blasting concentrated gamma radiation at
a chosen Target the creature has the
ability to impact the weather around it
dispersing storms that impede its
ability to move with ease and can reach
speeds up to 100 kilometers an hour in
spite of its immense power
scp-3700-1 is not aggressive and tends
to ignore beings in its vicinity other
than
scp-3700-2 speaking of
scp-3700-2 it is a 32 kilometer long
entity resembling a pelican eel in all
aspects except for its massive size and
the 13 appendages that encircle the
middle section of its body these
appendages which tuck inside its body
body when not in use are similar to the
tentacles of an octopus complete with
suckers the majority of the entity's
body consists of a sinewy tail
terminating in a sharp point when its
mouth is open it is an estimated three
kilometer steam its flesh is black and
it has white purple and red
bioluminescent lines in the shape of a
man's face on either side of its torso
scp-3700-2's anomalous properties
include the ability to invoke storms
with a severity of category 5 hurricanes
and the ability to produce whirlpools
that draw in any vessel within 150
meters so that it can rip them apart it
is also able to produce high-energy
sound waves as well as blue fire which
it emits from its esophagus when the two
entities interact it results in an epic
struggle as each begins attempts to
destroy or subdue the other when one is
Victorious immediate changes the area
follow when
scp-3700-1 wins the storms and harsh
weather in the area will immediately
calm and an era of fertility and
abundance will begin the reproductive
rates of fauna in the ocean and on the
Islands nearby increase threefold and
the crop yield doubles the ocean itself
becomes increasingly active and the
erosion rates of the archipelago Shores
increase five-fold when
scp-3700-2 wins however the weather
conditions become dangerous with raging
hurricanes rapidly fluctuating
temperatures and constantly changing
Storm fronts that cause destruction of
buildings and loss of life naturally
this renders any Ocean Travel in the
area extremely difficult or even
impossible aquatic food sources are
driven Away by harsh conditions the
livestock are killed by exposure and
disease crops are unable to thrive in
the high winds waterlogged soil and lack
of sunlight all the while
scp-3700-2 swims throughout the area
preying on unsuspecting ships and
menacing the coastline until
scp-3700-1 manifests to challenge it
again
scp-3700-2 will also regurgitate
instances of
scp-3456 though how or why this is
possible is unknown for those unfamiliar
with
scp-3456 they are a group of hairless
three-toed horse-like creatures with
thick translucent skin and human torsos
fuse to their backs they are most
frequently seen near sites of War
terrorist attacks and devastating
natural disasters direct observation of
one of these entities will draw their
attention to the Observer who the entity
will then stalk and capture before
disappearing due to their enormous size
and ability to anomalously manifest in
their home Waters
scp-3700-1 and 2 cannot be contained at
a foundation site instead their
containment is handled by Foundation
Naval task force Delta 7 Northern Storm
who Patrol the area in combination of
refurbished battleships destroyers
Cruisers and support craft additionally
measures have been taken to suppress
information about scp-3700 among the
general population details about the
unusual depth of the waters there have
been stricken from public texts and
scientific Publications
scp-3700-1 has been implanted with
dunovian Hollow projectors which
disguise it as a pod of humpback whales
if
scp-3700-1 encounters
scp-3700-2 Delta 7 main gauge protocol
winter Maelstrom this consists of
Destroyers deploying harpoon-based
anchors into
scp-3700-2's head to hold it in one
location next the vessels work together
to Target The Entity until
scp-3700-1 is able to subdue it if this
does not prove destructive and
scp-3700-2 cannot be contained then the
task force will Implement protocol
tumult at this point Naval and civilian
crafts in the area must be evacuated
trade and Ferry routes to the
archipelagos must be rerouted for at
least six months there will be constant
aerial and Naval engagement with
scp-3700-2 in constant monitoring for
the reappearance of
scp-3700-1 the behavior of scp-3700-1
and
scp-3700-2 is largely very predictable
with one notable exception on March 20th
2017 a pair of SCP foundation-owned
battleships known as the Mather and the
Terran arrived at a point between the
orkney Shetland and Pharaoh archipelagos
in the North Sea they were accompanied
by the usual Fleet of Delta 7 ships
approximately 600 meters away from the
ship's anchor points the water began to
emit intense bright rays of light for a
duration of three minutes at this point
scp-3700-1 appeared visible through the
surface of the water Delta 7 withdrew
their anchors speeding toward the entity
as the ships caught up to the entity it
raised two of its claws into the air
clicking them together in a friendly
greeting the Delta 7 ships followed the
entity along its usual swimming path for
30 minutes and during this time all was
peaceful but this peace did not endure
for long the tide began to change
literally as large black wall clouds
formed overhead the winds picked up and
the waves churn violently in response as
CP 3700-1 raised its claws overhead
waving them in a circular motion and
parting the clouds above it and Delta 7
but this effort took a lot out of the
creature and after 30 seconds its
antenna began to droop and it lowered
its claws still the hole in the clouds
remained allowing a spot of sunshine to
break through
down on the foundation vessels 600
meters ahead the ocean waters began to
rage and froth spraying foam and surf
into the Air
scp-3700-2 Bursts from beneath the
surface its head pointed upward it
continued to rise until the tops of its
tentacles could be seen just above the
water then stopped to bend its torso and
turn its head horizontally its jaw
unhinged exposing Rose upon rows of
serrated teeth the Beast let out a
mighty Roar accompanied by a stream of
blue flame at the site of its rival
scp-3700-1 doe beneath the surface
disappearing from view the scps mithir
ordered the rest of the vessels to
engage protocol winter Maelstrom Delta 7
scattered out from
scp-3700-1's point of submersion and all
13 destroyers fired their harpoons at
scp-3700-2 embedding themselves in the
entity's head naturally this enraged the
creature and he began to Roar and wail
spinning its lower body vigorously
enough to generate a Whirlpool the
Cruisers opened fire with a combination
of L cannons and conventional Weaponry
in order to distract The Entity as the
Destroyers pulled their Harpoon lines
taught dragging its head in a continuous
Circle while this was taking place the
battleships got into position and
prepared to fire on the Mather's Mark
three two one fire the first broadside
barrage collided with
scp-3700-2 and it grunted in pain
thrashing back and forth before opening
its mouth and spewing an instance of
scp-3456 into the water as soon as it
hit the water the equine monster began
to cut through at a pace of 50
kilometers an hour making its way toward
the Destroyers particularly the scps
selky the selki attempted to retarget
its weapons and prevent the creature
from reaching it but the monster moved
two quickly for the selky to adjust the
sulky was lifted out of the water by the
creature as crew members desperately
clung to the railings and their Weaponry
as the crew cowered and tried to fend
off the creature it'd reached for them
trying to pull them from the ship while
the sulky was occupied
scp-3700-2 was able to attack again
blasting another ship with a stream of
blue fire a loud crack rang out from
across the sea as the selkie dropped
back into the water the scp-3456 instant
shrieking in pain
scp-3700-1 burst through the surface
striking the creature with its club-like
limbs each blow emitting another loud
crack the third blow tore the instance
in half sending its human torso
careening through the air and past the
scps mithir freed from its attack the
selki moved full steam ahead pulling the
Harpoon line taught again and dragging
scp-3700-2 out of its path several silky
crewman members were thrown overboard
during the struggle and as they
struggled to keep their heads above
water
scp-3700-1 scooped them up placing them
onto the deck of a nearby destroyer and
out of Harm's Way with the crew members
rescued
scp-3700-1 set its sights on its enemy
swimming towards the edge of the
whirlpool and emitting a luminescent
glow from two of its eyes the constant
barrage of cannon fire on
scp-3700-2 was beginning to take its
toll and the mythor ordered the fleet to
quote brace for the killing blow as if
responding to the Mather's call
scp-3700-1 shot several concentrated
blasts of gamma radiation at its foe
leaving large holes in the creature in
their wake
scp-3700-2 screened flailing so hard
that it snapped the Harpoon lines and
created waves large enough to push the
vessels backward with its Newfound
Freedom
scp-3700-2 impaled scp-3700 1 through
the midsection with its Barbed tip of
its tail lifting it up and out of the
water with the force of the blow
scp-3700-1 desperately trying to free
itself attacking the tail with its
club-like limbs but the fight was in
vain and after a moment all movement
stopped
scp-3700-1 was for at least the duration
of this manifestation dead
scp-3700-2 tossed the corpse into the
water flinging it past Delta 7 where it
crashed into the water and sank down
Into the Depths below at this point
Delta 7 was ordered to initiate protocol
tumult the Delta 7 vessels turned away
from
scp-3700-2 and prepared to evacuate the
area one of the ships the scps strasony
Beast slowed behind the rest of the
fleet emitting concerning amounts of
smoke before coming to a stop meanwhile
the enraged and then boldened
scp-3700-2 expanded the size of its
whirlpool setting its sights on the
retreating ships and the weakened
strassany Beast the ship tried to flee
but the engines were completely shot and
would not respond the ship was caught in
the whirlpool and pulled against its
will toward
scp-3700-2 as the crew looked on in
helpless dread a tentacle Rose from the
deep wrapping around the vessel and
dragging it toward the entity escaping
maw suddenly
scp-3700-1 exploded from beneath the
surface of the water leaping between the
ship and
scp-3700-2 cutting the tentacle in half
and freeing the strassany beast from its
grip
scp-3700-2 shrieked before closing its
jaws and biting down on
scp-3700-1 it retaliated emitting bright
flashes of light and doing enough damage
to stop
scp-3700-2 from continuing to produce
its Whirlpool another tentacle emerged
from the water polling at
scp-3700-1's legs and ripping from its
body but scp-3700-1 returned the assault
in kind bludgeoning
scp-3700-2 with its club-like limbs from
inside of its mouth all at once
scp-3700-2's lower jaw was torn out of
place dropping into the water with
scp-3700-1 still inside
scp-3700-2 thrashed futile growing
steadily weaker and weaker it released
one more stream of fire before
collapsing Delta 7 paused The Retreat
watching the scene for any sign of a
winner but after five minutes neither
entity had moved Delta 7 returned to the
site of the battle to investigate and
saw that neither entity was moving and
both appeared to be deceased shortly
after Delta 7 reached the area both
entities disappeared leaving a single
round unidentified object that sank
below the surface whereas CP 3700-1 had
just been the wall clouds overhead had
dispersed leaving standard cumulonimbus
clouds in their place the waters
themselves remain choppy unsure of how
to proceed the scps Mather sent a radio
transmission to command this is Delta 7
to command we read you down to seven
command replied we have a bit of a
situation go ahead down to seven
scp-3700-1 and 2 are both down command
was silent for 10 seconds utterly
baffled by the information please repeat
Delta 7 again the mittler said
scp-3700-1 and 2 are both down command
ordered the MR2 standby three minutes of
radio silence later communication
resumed as they asked are either
entities effects active ah negative
command is there any trace of either
entity also negative it appears the
anomaly has been neutralized Delta 7 is
to return to base for debrief following
any recovery efforts with their next
steps clear Delta us of an attached the
strassany bees to several tugboats
preparing to pull the vessel to safety
but there was one more surprise waiting
the scps Mather began picking up unusual
levels of gamma radiation as well as a
sonar contact at a depth of three
kilometers they called command
requesting permission to deploy
submersibles for exploration purposes
one minute of Silence followed as the
command arrived at the decision request
denied return to base for debriefing and
so Delta 7 began to evacuate the area
once more steaming in the opposite
direction of the battle over the next
five minutes CCTV cameras on the vessels
picked up an unusual sight as the gamma
radiation levels continued to increase
the ocean turbulence also worsened
tossing smaller vessels and nearly
causing them to capsize then all of a
sudden the water stilled and four large
yellow orbs appeared below the surface
approximately 300 meters from Delta 7.
they lingered their there for two
minutes before Vanishing afterward a new
sonar contact was detected five
kilometers deep directly beneath the
task force command we've lost the signal
from the previous contact and are no
longer detecting gamma radiation we're
detecting new contact five kilometers
deep large and metallic after further
deliberation command responded Delta 7
you are authorized to deploy
submersibles for exploration purposes we
advise should
scp-3700-2 manifest exploration teams
are to be considered lost and you are to
return to base the consequences of this
incident as well as what else might be
lurking down in the depths beneath
scp-3700 are still unknown researcher
Martin pushed the deck against the door
hoping it would hold long enough for him
to find an alternate Escape Route he
wasn't thinking about the long term he
couldn't afford to with the foundation's
global reach he'd never truly Escape
them never be able to make it away
condemned to spend and the rest of his
life on the run from the organization he
devoted his life to it was too
overwhelming to even attempt to reckon
with that especially with the pounding
of a fist against the door he scrabbled
around opening Windows to try and see if
there was a safe way down technically
none of this was his fault at least in
his mind the administrative login
information he'd used to access the file
shouldn't have been left so easy to find
that was just poor cyber security on the
foundation's part researcher Martin had
been tasked with compiling information
on scp-001 one of the most infamous
anomalies ever encountered in the
foundation's long and storied history or
multiple of them at least what Martin
had come to learn was there were
numerous entities within the
foundation's files that all acted as
proposals for
scp-001 some were creatures the typical
kind of anomalous entities the
foundation dealt with on a regular basis
but some of the proposals focused on
more abstract anomalies and somehow
those were more existentially terrifying
than any evil Godlike being bent on
destroying reality theories about the
very source of anomalies themselves that
their very existence might have been
predetermined by some otherworldly Force
then there were the other proposals that
name parts of the foundation as the true
scp-001 those seem to suck researcher
mountain in like a Vortex dragging him
down a deep dark rabbit hole that made
him start to question everything he
thought he knew about working for the
SCP Foundation and the one that had
toppled him into a full-blown conspiracy
obsessed stupor that there was no coming
back from the Noir box proposal the
weighted head of a battering ram
splintered the wooden surface of the
door spraying fragments over the room
the table propped up to keep it shut
toppled under the force of the entry as
a squad of shadowy figures in full black
combat gear Rush inside the mobile task
force surrounded the cowering researcher
keeping their weapons trained on him
researcher Martin pleading for his life
started gesturing to the walls of the
room around him that had been plastered
with hastily scrawled diagrams and
equations Martin tried desperately to
find some concise easy to understand way
of explaining to the soldiers what he'd
uncovered they only picked up on a few
words like many worlds hypothesis and
splitting universes But ultimately they
didn't follow what he was saying and
weren't sent there to hear him out all
the MTF had been told was that
researcher Martin had breached
Foundation security and now posed a risk
of exposing sensitive information about
scp-001 there was only one path of
recourse termination however unbeknownst
to them Dr Martin was fine at least a
version of him was one who never learned
about the Noir box proposal for scp-001
and hadn't gone mad trying to unravel
its Mysteries instead he was a respected
higher ranking member of the foundation
who was alive and well in a completely
different timeline the formation of the
SCP Foundation has always been shrouded
in mystery with nobody really knowing
what the true origin of the organization
is and what is merely just a cover story
left in the archives to keep the truth
hidden
scp-001 the Noir box proposal at least
might hold the answers to the questions
surrounding how the foundation came to
be three times over known as the
tindalos Trinity the file pertaining to
this anomaly is buried deep in the SCP
foundation's database under layers upon
layers of encryption and security
clearance requirements it requires
someone at the very top level of the
foundation to access a member of either
the overseer Council or the foundation's
high command or OverWatch but wait what
are those are they the same thing well
yes and no the exact name of the
high-ranking secretive group that runs
the foundation has often been
interchangeable whether they're known as
the o5 council the overseer Council Etc
but what if it wasn't just many
different names for the same governing
body but actually separate names for
alternate versions of the ones who
control the SCP Foundation allow us to
explain all three of these groups the
overseer Council High command and
OverWatch have come to a consensus that
scp-001 is an anomaly that connects with
the foundation's very origin they
believe that the founder of the SCP
Foundation also known as scp-001 was
anomalous in some way that caused them
to interact with time in an unusual
fashion the triumviron of councils are
in agreement that around the time that
the SCP Foundation was formed three
distinct timelines were generated given
the anomalous nature of the
organization's founder each of these
timelines drastically altered the nature
of SCP p001 featuring a different
version in each one in the first
commonly known as timeline HC where the
foundation is run by a high command
scp-001 was an anomalous human corpse
this timeline's scp-001 still exhibited
all the behavioral characteristics of a
normal human being but could
additionally replicate itself at an
erratic uncontrollable rate usually when
performing tasks that could have
multiple possible outcomes
scp-001 and timeline HC also interacted
anachronistically with its environment
passing through solid matter that
predated it or would Outlast it so it
had to be contained in a room that was
constructed before it existed as an
anomaly this timelines scp-001 was
responsible for conceiving the idea for
the SCP Foundation and was able to
promote a significant interest in the
organization however they were
assassinated before the foundation was
officially codified with the culprits
being a version of mobile task force Alp
0 or believed to have originated from
either of the other two timelines while
this seems to have been done to deter
the foundation forming in this timeline
it seems to have had the opposite effect
despite the assassination of scp-001
occurring before the official formation
of the SCP Foundation and timeline HC
this version of the foundation was
successfully codified by the 13 members
of what they referred to as high command
given the anomalous circumstances around
the death of scp-001 it provided the
Catalyst for the organization to
immediately establish itself as this
timeline's protection against the threat
posed by anomalous entities the body of
scp-001 was placed in the building that
had been its childhood home securing it
somewhere that predated them to negate
their anomalous properties this made
them the first anomaly contained by
timeline hc's version of the SCP
Foundation posthumously garnering the
them the official designation of
scp-001 so that's the first of our three
timelines at play the events that unfold
in the second are considerably different
in this timeline timeline OC the
foundation was initially created by a
different
scp-001 this entity referred to
primarily as the founder appropriately
enough was a human being known to
possess anomalous temporal abilities the
founder was known to also be immortal
showing no visible signs of aging and
with a resistance to external damage
that prevented him from being directly
killed any injuries he sustained could
be healed but only at the same rate
typical of an average human being the
temporal side of his anomalous
properties pertain to predicting the
future the founder was able to with an
inaugurable level of precision and
accuracy forecast events before they
occurred his foresight had appeared to
the foundation was not inciting these
events to happen as he predicted them
however everything he he ever predicted
would occur became an inevitability
impossible to delay avert or alter
through any means during the events of
timeline OC and as his preferred
nickname implies the founder was the
sole figure responsible for establishing
this version of the SCP Foundation in
this course of events the o5 Council of
this timeline were known as the overseer
Council it was however while he was in
the process of establishing the
organization that things started to go
awry whether he was able to predict this
occurrence or not is unknown although it
seems to have corresponded with the MTF
Alp zero assassination of scp-001 in the
other timeline timeline HC in Timeline
OC at the same time as the assassination
in Timeline HC the founder began to
exhibit his anomalous temporal
properties in front of the original
members of overseer Council however it
should also be noted that there was no
recorded presence of MTF Alp zero in
Timeline OC believing the founder to be
a potential danger to the foundation
they had all helped to create the
founding overseer Council classified him
as an anomalous threat they immediately
devised a set of containment measures
for the founder now designating him as
scp-001 the first anomaly contained by
this timeline's version of the
foundation he was placed within a
standard humanoid containment cell and
given regular meals while Personnel were
forbidden to communicate with him given
his role in establishing the foundation
in this version of events
scp-001 is naturally in favor of
containing and analyzing anomalies
however not when that includes him and
insisted that he be released according
to one of his predictions for
forthcoming events he requested to be
allowed to build a device but refused to
elaborate on the intended purpose of it
scp-001 even refused to allow other
members of foundation Personnel to
construct the device on his behalf for
testing purposes the third of these
timelines is referred to as timeline ow
wherein the leading body of the
foundation are known as OverWatch here
just like the previous iterations of its
history the description of scp-001 and
their role in forming the SCP Foundation
differs in this timeline
scp-001 is an anomaly that consists of
two distinct Parts the first of these is
a figured not dissimilar from the
founder referred to as
scp-001-1 this person is also a
functionally Immortal human who doesn't
age and can't heal rapidly from damage
scp-001-1 also advocates for securing
and analyzing anomalies however this
includes himself as he doesn't object to
his own containment or that of the
second component of this as cp001 known
as
scp-001-a this device is capable of
accurately calculating any and all
possible outcomes of any event that is
input into it unlike the founder who
seemed to possess a foresight able to
predict the only inevitable outcome of
the future
scp-001-a is able to account for the
possibility of multiple potential
Futures even down to accounting for how
its own predictions could potentially
influence or alter outcomes in layman's
terms at least one of the eventualities
predicted by
scp-001-a will always be accurate unless
the predictions are to do with its own
future or the future of
scp-001-1 in this instance the device
will always produce one of two
assumptions that are incorrect either
that scp-001-1 was killed after an
assassination attempt and never
constructed as
cp001-a but that's impossible after all
as CPS 001-a exists it's already been
made in this timeline the other
incorrect prediction it can give is that
scp-001-1 also exhibits the same
anomalous properties as the prediction
machine more akin to the founder and
that
scp-001-a was never constructed in the
first place but again that can't be
right in this timeline anyway according
to records within timeline ow their
version of the founder who is of course
as cp001-1 encountered a version of
mobile task force Alp Zero from one of
the other timelines they presented the
founder of the ow timeline with detailed
blueprints for the construction of
scp-001-a the device's completion
coincided with the assassination in
Timeline HC and the corresponding
anomalous incident in Timeline OC after
this point MTF alpzero departs from
timeline ow this version of the SCP
Foundation is then created to study the
device
scp-001-a with this founder and a group
of his close friends who would become
this foundation's OverWatch following
this initial research group's discovery
of other anomalous phenomenon that
threatened the rest of society the
team's goal expanded to research
anomalies and protect the world from the
danger they posed however the rest of
the OverWatch began to age at a natural
range while the founder didn't recognize
this he volunteered to be contained and
studied thus becoming a component of
this timeline's
scp-001 stepping back and looking at all
these timelines there seems to be a
number of marked similarities
particularly relating to how the
foundation was established and how a
figure usually the one who founded the
organization possessed anomalous means
of interacting with time and temporality
under normal circumstances interaction
between alternate timelines should be
impossible but the preservation of
information about all three on the SCP
foundation's database has somehow
enabled all three timelines to
communicate with each other through
exchanging intelligence via their own
versions of the database all three
iterations of the foundation across the
three timelines have learned that almost
all of the anomalies they have
encountered since being established are
exclusive to their own timeline there
are a total of 17 anomalies that have
been confirmed to exist across the three
timelines but there is a concerning
factor in all this the presence of an
anachronistic military group referring
to itself as MTF Alp zero this mobile
task Force's direct involvement in the
events of both timeline HC where they
assassinated scp-001 and timeline ow
where they provided schematics for
scp-001-a raises an awful lot of
questions this MTF had to be acting on
orders of the foundation but which
version in which timeline the consensus
among the leading Committees of all
three the high command overseer Council
and OverWatch is that at some unknown
date in the future each of them will
inevitably send their own version of MTF
Alp zero back in time to alter the
foundation's past and in a sense they've
already done it and seen how this
altered the circumstances in order to
inadvertently create the foundation this
poses the risk of one of these timelines
overriding another thus meaning all
information garnered by alternate
iterations of the foundation could be
lost so putting their heads together
these Foundation leading committees come
to the conclusion that they need to
attempt to merge all three timelines and
it seems the way to do so is using the
device that timeline OC's founder wanted
to build and that timeline ow's founder
was able to construct this device is how
this proposal for scp-001 was given its
nickname the Noir box the intention of
the Noir box is to shunt all three
timelines into a stable joint path like
turning loose strands into a single
length of twine as such the leading
Committees of all three different
timelines have agreed to share their
Intel on how each of them can safely
create their own Noir boxes and all
three will be used to merge the
timelines every member of high command
the overseer Council and OverWatch sign
off on it but whether or not the plan
works is another matter the fabric of
time is delicate and one wrong move
could tear everything apart there are
places in the Multiverse that human
beings were never meant to find worlds
populated with swarms of crawling
spiders isolated dimensional prisons
were faceless corpses mimic the living
and Realms bathed in the purest Darkness
were a glimmer of Light May reveal more
than what a visitor might ever want to
see these places serve to remind us that
every one of us is before any other
essential quality of our collective
experience alone every human mind is an
isolated incident struggling to make
sense of every environment while hoping
to find common ground with the other
people in our lives we strive to
understand others and be understood but
sadly it is often the case that we must
interact with fellow human beings whose
motivations seem alien to us all too
frequently we are surrounded by people
we cannot relate to in situations we
have little control over and even if we
make attempts to articulate ourselves
there will always be an insurmountable
Gulf between the limits of our
experience and others as far as each of
us knows we are the only free willed
individuals in the cosmos and even the
nature of that Free Will is deeply in
question while many of us become
overwhelmed by these bigger questions
and are forced to confront our inherent
loneliness there is an instinct to turn
to unfeeling things for answers surely
the vast expanse of creation that made
us must have done so for a reason most
of who ask that question spend their
entire lives waiting for confirmation of
that reason they reach out for something
or somewhere that they are meant to be
it is only the vanishing rare few that
find it an unmistakable answer in an
unspeakable place a terrifying Vista of
Madness that all but scream
you will never belong
scp-507 The Reluctant Dimension Hopper
has found himself in places like these
more times than he is able to count he
has seen the spiders the room of corpses
that mimic human activity and has peered
through the darkness assisted by a
flashlight and seeing only the smiling
face of a humanoid monster there are
dozens more frightening and unsettling
universes that scp-507 has encountered
and all known instances have been
archived in document
scp-507-3b any one of the innumerable
Horrors that this otherwise ordinary
human male has endured would send a
shiver down the spine of the best of us
but unfortunately this is little Comfort
to a CPE 507 facing down The Madness of
the abyss and returning intact starts to
become less triumphant when it is a
weekly sometimes daily occur
the dimension Hopper can barely have a
moment of Peace in this life as his
irregular shifts into different
realities occur without any warning and
all the research that the foundation has
done on scp-507 seems to indicate that
there will never be an end to these
trips into the infinite but no end does
not necessarily imply the lack of a
beginning the tragic existence of
scp-507 could not have started without a
cons and part of the foundation's goal
in containing
scp-507 is to discern an explanation for
the humanoid signature unstable mode of
inter-dimensional travel so far the
experiments have raised one burning
question after another with scp-507
himself having difficulty recounting
some of the stranger aspects of the
dimension he hops into and in a grander
sense what it might all mean but the
foundation has no choice but to listen
intently to a scp-507 and take notes on
everything he says in regards to his
condition after all the phenomenon of
Leaping to other worlds primarily affect
the dimension Hopper himself and can
really only be understood through a
thorough understanding of the subject
over the course of many interviews with
scp-507 the research team has pieced
together what they believe might be the
definitive history of The Reluctant
Dimension Hopper from his native reality
to the flux of ever-changing hellscapes
that occupies his current days while it
is impossible to verify due to the
imperfect nature of memory and the
countless traumas suffered by scp-507
the foundation believes that this record
can be used as a case study for further
investigation into the Multiverse itself
on a less practical level the interviews
can help the foundation to improve
containment for scp-507 and make sure
that his existence is as lacking in
unnecessary suffering as possible we're
going back to the beginning
to the earliest dimensional hops that
scp-507 can remember in detail
considering the persistent nature of
scp-507's anomalous capabilities it was
hardly surprising for the foundation to
learn that the humanoid did not have a
conventional childhood 507 has never
made any mention of identifiable
biological parents nor of any Grade
School Educational facility public or
private in the absence of these markers
of normalcy
scp-507 describes spending an
indeterminate amount of his formative
years in a Fantastical realm known as
limonora though it has apparently been
decades since scp-507 has hopped into
luminora he was able to describe the
dimension in great detail a grassy plane
of a run with red honeycomb standing
stones that seemed to sing with
thousands of beautiful voices as the
wind blew through them the Skies of
luminora were colored a velvety bluish
purple which never got any dimmer than a
a commercial night light there were
shallow streams of spring water that
seemed to run in all directions
regardless of elevation there were also
dangers in luminora flocks of swooping
Birds which scp-507 described as having
the appearance of skinless vultures
these vultures would often attempt to
capture scp-507 and bring him to a
location known as the dawnwell as one
might expect 507 was never actually
apprehended by the creatures but insists
that these were more than ordinary Birds
of Prey vultures don't hunt for live
human children being scavengers after
all it has also been made clear that 507
was the only human of any sort in
limonora this has led the researchers to
conclude that he most likely wasn't born
in that reality and that previously
hopped there from a dimension of origin
that remains inaccessible due to his
lack of memories during infancy the
dimension Hopper claims that his best
friend finnicker always protected him
from these avian threats finnicker was
another creature native to limonora who
resembled an anomalous crustacean the
size of a large dog covered in what
scp-507 believed to be a coat of tufted
brown fur when fending off the vultures
vinegar carried a heavy cudgel in one of
his claws the blunt instrument was said
to be carved from the same material as
the musical Standing Stones additionally
507 has remarked that the inside of
vinegar's shell was mostly Hollow and
could be used as a shelter and resting
place for the young Dimension Hopper as
long as he had the continued friendship
of the creature many researchers who
have taken statements from scp-507
regarding the menorah have reflexively
come to view the unconfirmed dimension
and 507's experiences therein as the
product of a wild imagination made more
Vivid due to a traumatic upbringing on
the other hand
scp-507 insists that limonora is not a
psychological coping ISM and is in fact
just as real as all the other dimensions
he has hopped into it is difficult to
dismiss his account entirely as no
matter how many times scp-507 is asked
about lemonor and how far apart the
interviews are the details of the
account never seem to deviate from what
had previously been established during
his time in limonora which may have
spanned more than a year 507 has stated
that he was the happiest that he had
ever been whenever he wasn't avoiding
the vultures of The Well of dawn 507
past time by listening to the music from
The Standing Stones surfing the erratic
currents of the shallow streams and
learning rudimentary carving techniques
with finnicker in some ways limonora was
a paradise for a child there was no
homework or chores and whenever it was
safe he could play outside as much as he
wanted it wasn't until one terrible
night that everything about his isolated
existence changed for the worst while
falling asleep inside feniker's shell
scp-507 experienced a random dimensional
shift to a deep and forbidding Force at
first he thought this new reality was a
dream as it was abnormally dark and
Misty nothing like lemonora then he saw
them the so-called mammal men
scp-507 remembered their chattering
teeth long and orange like beaver's
teeth as well as the leathery pale skin
that covered their misshapen bodies the
mammal men roared and hissed making
unnatural noises as they chewed into the
trees the sound of it all was very
distressing for young
scp-507 who began to flee from the
strange humanoids into the nearby bushes
he cried out for finnicker hoping that
his friend would arrive and protect him
but it didn't happen and try as he might
it seemed as though he couldn't wake up
from this nightmare it wasn't a
nightmare at all in fact but a true
dimensional shift from which there could
be no easy return terrified for reasons
Beyond his comprehension the young
dimensional Hopper continued to cry out
for his only friend the was a sudden
crack and allowed whoosh as one of the
great trees of the forest came toppling
down in his Direction
scp-507 braced himself for the
inevitable impact but it never came he
was in what appeared to be a city now
and it was the middle of the day crowds
of human beings surrounded him and the
sounds of automobiles and phone calls
drowned his mind in the cacophony it was
a total sensory overload compared to
limonora and being exposed to it after
having such a harrowing experience in
the forest Dimension caused scp-507 to
break down into tears he continued to
weep and call out for finnicker but his
crustacean friend was several Worlds
Away now when the authorities eventually
arrived given a call about a lost child
scp-507 was brought to the nearby police
station the officers tried to ask
scp-507 questions presumably about where
his parents were or where his home was
but 507 recalls being unable to
understand the language they were
speaking and thus there was no hope of
communication the adults seemed equally
frustrated and tried speaking to the
child in a number of different languages
eventually when no parent or Guardian
appeared to claim the child it was
determined that scp-507 would be placed
in foster care from their scp-507 was
given to a family that soon became his
legal Guardians he was homeschooled on
many of the basic subjects of Science
and Math and learned the English
language through constant tutoring while
his new parents and siblings were
willing to entertain his stories of
limonora and finnicker they believed it
was little more than the fantasy of an
imaginary friend throughout the rest of
his youth
scp-507 experienced no unusual Dimension
hopping and began to live a relatively
normal and unremarkable life at a
certain point he even began to believe
that limonora never existed none of the
other children he knew had ever
experienced something like it the fact
that they would constantly remind him of
in their ruthless teasing even so
scp-507 entered his teen years as a
shockingly normal individual given the
circumstances while the foundation has
never been able to verify the names and
identities of his foster family members
mostly because scp-507 has been
reluctant to divulge any related
information his seeming loyalty to
keeping the people who raised him
anonymous is proof enough that this
chapter of his life was not fabricated
according to scp-507's testimony the
involuntary shifting began to reoccur
not long after he had gone through
puberty the sudden disappearance is
worried his family and many times they
believed that he had attempted to run
away from home this also had an impact
on his social and educational
development as maintaining both
friendships and good grades in high
school were difficult when he could
disappear for days and weeks at a time
the vast majority of these dimensional
leaps are uneventful Beyond The Strain
they put on
scp-507's efforts at a normal life but
one in particular has left a lasting
impact on 507 it was during a Halloween
block party in his senior year when
scp-507 shifted away during an attempt
to refill his punch he blinked in shock
to find himself in limonora once more
but it was not as he had left it the sky
was a deep shade of maroon and cracked
like a glass surface from there these
cracks spilled sand like rain onto the
now desolate Plains and dried up Rivers
The Standing Stones were mostly broken
and there was no wind to conduct them
into their song the teenage 507 wandered
around this ruined limonora in disbelief
the Fantastical place he remembered had
been real for his entire life but now it
was dead if that wasn't traumatizing
enough nothing could prepare him for
what awaited at The Well of dawn near
the strange pit of emanated sunlight was
the rotted sunbleached shell of a
massive station vinegar 507 barely had
any time to take in the sight of his
long-lost friend before he was returned
to the roof of the Halloween party that
was the last time he ever saw the world
of lemonorah but it was far far from the
most horrific sites that the Multiverse
would have to offer want to own an SCP
of your own go to scpswag.com for
premium anomalous merchandise now go
check out scp-507 reluctant Dimension
Hopper and can scp-096 chase its victims
across the Multiverse for more
interdimensional Adventures from scp-507